okay you should be good to
begin as chair of the house Ways and
Means Committee I find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rulle 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet rically this is a joint Ways and
Means Committee economic briefing please
note there is no physical lo location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporar to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order number one I am confirming
confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporarily during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporarily cly listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website notices for this meeting
complies with house rules RSA
911-a anyone who has a problem ACC in
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email HCS
l.n. Us in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us which is Jennifer
FL and Christopher Shay from the
legislative budget office please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting should be done by roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call of attendants when each
members States their presence please
also State whether there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to no
law thank you representative Bon you
want to take the role thank you Mr chair
good morning everyone uh representative
abrami Adam at home alone thank you
representative
Griffin representative who Griffin
that's you yeah I'm president I'm home
alone at my at my home in Windam okay
good morning Mary good morning
representative
oy I'm home my wife's in the house
someplace
representative
ducet representative ducet
representative burin is your clerk I'm
in beautiful Nottingham New Hampshire in
Elliott representative Elliot
representative
janigian RG janigian janigian I'm sorry
that's okay you don't mind if I correct
you I I don't it's I'm fine um I'm here
uh in Salem New Hampshire with my wife
and daughter somewhere in the house okay
representative
Nunes good morning I'm present and I'm
at home alone in Pelham representative
Baxter thank you representative bur time
I'm here alone by myself at my home
representative spillsbury good morning
present at home my wife swh in the house
in Charlestown New Hampshire
representative Tudor I'm here alone in
my seller in Northwood wife and
grandkids are upstairs representative
Aly home alone in in Lebanon on
representa thank you representative Ames
yes I'm here and Jeffrey in my home
office
alone representative
Southworth representative Southworth I'm
home alone in do representative Mal
yes I'm home uh alone in
Greenland representative
shamberg uh representative shamberg in
wilmet my wife's in the home
representative
Tucker yes I'm here alone in
Randol representative
garlo representative garlo in Swansea by
lofman representative
gorg I am here alone in my home office
in Lee representative hackin Phillips
present this morning alone in my office
in conquer representative Murphy present
here in Handover my wife and daughter
are elsewhere in the house
representative
major I'm here in my home with my wife
in the other room in
plasto Senator Gary
Daniels Senator Gary Daniels I'm at my
home in Milford and I'm alone Senator
GAA Senator GAA at my home in Warren my
daughter and Grandson are in a remote
part of the house representative
Hennessy Senator Aon Hennessy I am at my
home in Littleton and my children are in
the house with
me that's Senator Hennessy my apologies
Senator Hennessy Senator Rose renald
Cindy Rosenwald from nashv I'm in my
home and my husband is around Senator
delis
Andro okay it looks like there's 24 of
representative
this morning we'll start off uh with
with Jeffrey Schultz who's the CFA
director he's a investment strategist
and overseas Capital Market and
Economist researcher contributing
on economic topics that is frequently
quoted in the financial media media
including the Wall Street Journal CNBC
and CNN he joined clairbridge investment
in
2014 has 15 years of investment industry
experience prior to joining clearbridge
Jeffrey was a portfolio specialist at L
Abbot and Company LLC he received his BS
in finance from rutley University he's a
member of the CFA
thank you and good morning everybody um
so my name is Jeffrey Schultz and uh I'm
the investment strategist with
clearbridge here to give you an update
uh for uh what we expect to happen here
in
2021 um I'm in the process of trying to
share my screen here but it does appear
that uh I am unable to do so we be able
to uh share my screen to show you some
some slides on what we anticipate here
for the economy U Jen you
I just I just updated the setting my
much you full screen mode okay so um
obviously after 2020 um there's a off
the expectation for 2021 and I think
those expectations will certainly be met
um for the narrative for throughout the
course of last year though we were
really focusing on whether or not uh we
had seen a durable economic and market
bottom in the us and uh we the reason
the way that we've been able to do this
sorry about this uh the way that we're
moning this was with our proprietary
recovery dashboard a group of nine
variables that have done an excellent
job of foreshadowing a durable economic
and market bottom it's a reverse
stoplight analogy so the goal here was
to go from a red recession to a yellow
Improvement ultimately to a green
expansion color and you can see the
entire progression of the dashboard over
the course of 2020 where the dashboard
is flashing a red recession at the end
of March as the US economy is going
through shutdowns as we've transitioned
to June uh the dashboard is flashing a
green expansion at that point we're
advocating to our clients to upgrade and
risk take on more beta in their
portfolios uh to take advantage of this
budding economic recovery and it's
continued to get more green if you will
throughout the course of 2020 but as it
stands as of year end we have seven
green one red and one yellow signal uh
and I think it's really clear at this
point that we have seen in fact a
durable economic and market bottom um
I'm not sure I'm going to get much push
back from the group here considering
that the S&P 500 was up 68% through the
lows into the year end and third quarter
GDP came in at
33.4% but if you think about that
recover it I think it was very
interesting and dynamic in two specific
facets first off earnings came in much
higher than anticipated um in the second
and third quarter of last year earnings
beats were much stronger than what you
saw during the last recovery
in fact it was the strongest earnings
beats that you've seen since 1996 and
looking so far here at fourth quarter
earnings that have come out um it does
appear that analysts are underestimating
the earnings potential for the S&P 500
yet again and it's going to surprise to
the upside now the earnings came in much
better than anticipated obviously
because companies cut costs very
dramatically and quickly but the other
half of the equation was that you saw an
economy uh come on very strongly and U
the big question the middle part of last
year is what was the shape of the US
economy's recovery going to be and
against consensus expectations it ended
up being a v-shaped recovery and this is
best Illustrated through retail sales it
only took six months for retail sales to
recover their pre-recession Peak during
this recent crisis you compare that to
the.com Bubble it took much longer at 16
months and then the global financial
crisis it took almost three years but if
you look over at retail sales on the Le
hand side which is that red line you can
see that it's hook down here recently in
fact you've seen negative retail sales
prints on a month-over-month basis for
October November and December and a key
reason for that obviously is the
covid-19 crisis that the US is currently
dealing with you're seeing social
distancing measures come back into place
you're seeing economic retrenchment in
fact in 29 US states right now you're
seeing some form of restrictions on
indoor eating um but there is a key
difference between today and March uh
when you saw a large increase of cases
you saw a subsequent increase uh large
increase of deaths uh this time around
even though cases have spiked
dramatically deaths have only moved up
uh a fraction of what you saw earlier in
the year and it's a key reason obviously
why the US economy has continued to
remain open uh much more so than what
you saw at the end of the first quarter
but nonetheless because of covid and the
increase of hospitalizations and deaths
you are seeing economic retrenchment and
it's you're not only seeing it slow down
in retail sales but you're also seeing
it in the labor market Market as well
now the latest jobs uh joess claims
print that we got last week jumped up to
965 th000 consensus expectations were
for that jobs print to come in below
800,000 so that's a huge Spike and at
965 th000 job losses in a week prior to
covid that would have been the largest
weekly job loss in US history so you're
seeing pronounced weakness in the labor
market you're also seeing it with the
monthly uh jobs reports uh we got a
December report a couple weeks ago it
came in well below consensus
expectations at Nega 140,000 um that was
the weakest jobs report outside of March
and April that you've seen since the
global financial crisis and it has a lot
of people wondering whether or not this
is just an economic slowdown or that
whether or not this is a double dip
recession and because of that we've
reintroduced our recession risk
dashboard a group of 12 variables that
have done an excellent job of
foreshadowing whether or not a recession
is on the horizon it's a a stoplight
analogy but it's in the reverse this
time where the goal is to go from a
green expansion to a yellow caution
ultimately to a red recession uh and as
of the end of December we have seven
green three yellow and two red signals
but most importantly if you look at the
bottom of that First Column you have an
overall green signal which tells us that
this is just a Slowdown this isn't a
double dip recession and if you look all
the way to the left of the chart we
really try to look at the economy on the
three fault lines of economic activity
the very top there we're looking at
consumer health it's the biggest part of
the dashboard because it's the biggest
part of the US economy below that we
look at business activity obviously
businesses are responsible for hiring
and doing capex both of which have a
multiplier effect on economic activity
and then last but not least at the
bottom there we're looking at Financial
stresses because Financial stresses
usually emanate first before the economy
rolls over and I want to turn your
attention to the financial stresses
section all three of those indicators
right now are flashing a green expansion
color this shouldn't be a surprise to
anybody because if you look at the
Goldman Sachs Financial conditions index
it's the most accommodative in the
history of that Series so there's a lot
of liquidity squashing around in
financial markets but the other one I
want to point out is the second one
under business activity which is ISM
Manufacturing PMI new orders if you're
not familiar with manufacturing PMI all
it is it's a survey given to
manufacturers asking them how business
conditions are and also how business
conditions look to be in the future um
and the most forward-looking component
of that survey is the new orders
component and Manufacturing PMI new
orders is synonymous with the business
cycle when it accelerates with a 3 to
six month lag the US economy generally
accelerates when it decelerates with a
three to six month lag US economy tends
to slow and ISM Manufacturing PMI new
orders came in at a very strong print in
December at
67.9 which tells us even though you are
seeing some weakness in the labor
markets that this is Transit
and the economy is going to be able to
power through this the other thing I'll
mention about that jobs report that we
got for December the headline numbers
very negative at negative 140,000 job
losses but if you look beneath the
surface I look at that as a very strong
jobs report because if you hospitality
and Leisure job losses over the course
of the month were
498,000 and it's not surprising that
you're seeing massive job losses in
those sectors given the fact that you're
seeing economic retrenchment and a
return of social distancing um but if
you strip that cohort out the jobs
report was a very healthy
350,000 which shows you that the
underlying strength of the US economy is
resilient and the the underlying economy
is fine and once you get to the middle
part of this year a lot of those job
losses that you're seeing in hospitality
and Leisure will come back as the
economy gets back to
normalization now the other thing I'll
mention obviously whether or not this is
a Slowdown or a double dier session
we're clearly in the Slowdown camp and
and uh this there's a couple of reasons
why not only that the dashboard is
flashing a green expansion color but
also that the US economy is going to
reach her immunity sometime in the
second quarter or third quarter of this
year in fact if all the vaccines that
are expected to come online do um you're
going to have 5.1 billion shots
administered by the end of 2021 but US
economic activity is going to start to
accelerate well before herd immunity
because as you start to inoculate
Frontline workers and also the most
vulnerable and Community type living
living types of situations and the
elderly you're going to see a decrease
of hospitalizations you're going to see
a decrease of deaths and economic
activity will naturally start to
increase at that point uh but also even
though the US has stumbled out of the
gate um with their inoculation efforts
um you have started to see an increase
closer to that 1 million shot per day
administ admin level that was
anticipated as we moved into December so
I I feel by the end of this month we're
going to be reaching those levels we're
going to be well in our way to reaching
her immunity but once you reach her
immunity this is a key key determination
of trying to unlock a lot of the
consumer savings that have built up
since the beginning of the pandemic in
fact since the beginning of the pandemic
you have total excess savings on the
consumer balance sheets of $1.4
trillion That's not including the
stimulus package that was passed in
December with $600 checks going to every
American that's qualifies it doesn't
include the likely additional stimulus
that's coming out from the Democratic
package that was released here recently
um obviously you're probably going to
see some additional stimulus going to
Consumers so it wouldn't be a surprise
to me if you see total excess savings
north of $2 trillion dollar by the
middle part of this year and it's I
think once you get to that point you're
going to see Revenge spending deferred
gratification um people going to spend a
lot on services and going to really
juice economic growth in the back half
of the year and the one thing I think
that's really different today versus the
global financial crisis is people are
accumulating savings not because of
caution on the part of households but
they're accumulating savings because
they don't have the ability to spend on
Services uh because of Mobility
restrictions and her immunity will will
take away that hurdle and really unleash
a lot of this Capital but this is one of
the key reasons why we expect uh
economic activity above consensus
expectations for the next couple of
years also you're going to see a very
massive inventory rebuilding cycle in
the US uh inventory levels relative to
sales have not been this depleted since
2014 but now that businesses finally
have some visibility into the back half
of the year um they're going to unleash
a massive inventory rebuilding cycle in
order to anticipate that future demand
and this is really going to boost
manufacturing activity in the first half
of 2020 2021 I should say the other
thing that I think is going to boost
economic activity is the macro Trifecta
these three ingredients have been
crucial for fueling strong economic
rebounds that's long lower long rates so
a low 10-year treasury uh weaker energy
costs and a weaker dollar and if you
look at long low long low long rates and
a weaker energy cost they are much more
depressed than what you've typically
seen in an economic recovery and this
going to provide a Tailwind well into
2022 and it's clearly being reflected by
consensus expectations in 2021 it's
expected to be the best growth in the US
economy in over 20 years but this just
isn't a one-year phenomena off of easy
comps because of the recession in 2022
that's expected to be the best growth
since
2004 and this does not include the
stimulus that was passed in December and
the likely new stimulus is coming out
over the next couple of months uh which
is why we expect economic growth well
above consensus expectations of closer
to
6% and I I think there's a key
consideration here that I think Market
parti participants and policy makers are
really underestimating the massive
amount of savings that you've seen not
only on the consumer side but on the
corporate side of well side as well and
what that's going to do to juice
economic activity once you reach herd
immunity and uh I I think obviously with
policy makers underestimating that that
increase of activity um one of the the
key policy makers that I think are
underestimating what the US economy can
grow at is the Federal Reserve the FED
is clearly fighting the last battle
which is the global financial crisis and
uh they have their foot all the way down
on the accelerator and one of the ways
that you can see this is through
quantitative easing now the United
States has a much larger ability to do
quantitative easing versus the Euro zone
or Japan uh given the fact that our
balance sheet is much lower as a percent
of GDP but at present um the Federal
Reserve is doing $120 billion dollars
worth of bond purchases per month um and
they're not going to they're going to
continue to do that until they see
substantial further progress on both the
unemployment rate and inflation and
given the rosy optimistic Outlook that
we just talked about again 120 billion
per month is a massive number um it's
one and a half times larger than any
previous QE program that we've seen in
the US but also they're not only just
doing QE they've actually changed to an
average inflation targeting regime and
the key reason for this is because
they've willfully missed their two%
inflation Target since 2008 at the very
top of the screen you can see that
they've only hit that 2% Target three
times over the last 12 years so in order
to fix that they're going to make up for
those those that shortcoming and they're
going to let inflation run hot over 2%
for a prolonged period of time and uh
the two things that they're really
looking for in order to start raising R
rates is they want to see the
unemployment rate back to where they it
was prior to covid-19 which is
3.6% and they want to see inflation
sustainably above 2% for a period of
time now looking at the fed's Dot Plot
which is what their expectations are for
the unemployment rate and inflation it
goes out till the end of 2023 and at
that point the FED expects the
unemployment rate to be at 3.7% which
will be close to the Target that they've
outlined but they only see inflation
being 2% at that time um so from the
fed's vantage point they don't see
themselves raising rates until 2024 at
the earliest and this is a really
important consideration because usually
the FED has their fingerprints on most
recessions as they start to raise rates
in anticipation of inflation they
usually raise rates a little bit too
much and end up causing a recession this
time around the FED is recognized that
raising rates too early is more
detrimental to the US economy than
raising rates later and they're not
going to get in the way of this economic
expansion that we have in front of us
and uh they're going to let the economy
run hot over the course of the next
couple of years now this is a very
important backdrop for the economy and
risk assets but one of the things that I
I think is an important consideration
here is that the two recoveries that we
have today versus the global financial
crisis couldn't be more different first
off one of the big differences is the
origin of the the recession this
recession that we recently has was
caused by an exogenous event and the
economy was in Fairly good position and
you know very fairly strong position as
the economy shut down back during the
global financial crisis you had
pre-existing conditions with an
overheated housing market an
overextended consumer and Bank leverage
issues and it really took three or four
years to work out those issues before
the economy can start to accelerate and
heal on its own and we just don't have
that overhang this time around the
second difference is the policy
prescription today was exactly the right
one policy makers came out forcefully
and aggressively they got business
businesses and consumers access to
Capital in a fast and efficient manner
um back during the global financial
crisis it took a long time to calibrate
the right policy response and because of
that you had longer and deeper scarring
uh last cycle and the other difference
is the health of health of the average
household um households are in very good
shape because of a strong housing market
financial markets are up substantially
from the lows obviously had an abundance
of fiscal stimulus and the inability to
spend and versus the end of 2019
household net worth is up 5.2 trillion
doar um that's going to go a long way to
helping this recovery unfold over the
next couple of years but maybe the
biggest difference between the two uh
recessions and recoveries is found in
the labor market now what we're looking
at here is the nfib small business
hiring plans survey and if you're not
familiar with the nfib survey it's the
premier small business survey it took
until 2014 to regain pre-recession
levels coming out of the global
financial crisis today we've already
recovered it in less than nine months
looking at us job openings it's a
similar situation it took until 2014 to
get back to pre-recession levels we
today us job openings are where we were
as we went into Co 19's crisis and this
is a very important consideration
because if you have a lot of job
openings out there that means that you
can see a labor market that heals much
faster than anticipated and much faster
Trend economic growth and this crisis
77% of the job losses were in covid
sensitive Industries and as we reach her
immunity and we get to some level of
normalization again these are going to
be jobs and the job Creation in that
industry is going to happen much quicker
than what we saw just a decade ago
you're also seeing a difference in
confidence again this is the nfib survey
which is that Premier small business
survey in the US took until 2014 to get
to pre-recession levels we're already at
that point currently and if you think
about one cohort that should be hurting
the most from the crisis it's small
businesses because a lot of their uh
business models rely on face-to-face
interactions and with social distancing
and economic retrenchment it's hitting
small businesses the hardest um but
clearly they are they're very confident
even in light of the economic slowdown
that we've seen here recently you're
also seeing it in the CEO Roundtable
business confidence survey again we're
at pre- recessionary levels there and if
you have business confidence that means
businesses will invest in the future
they're going to do capex they're going
to hire of course that all has a
multiplier effect on the economy you're
seeing business confidence in a
different way as well through business
formation applications back in the
global financial crisis not surprisingly
you saw business formation applications
plummet uh all the way through the
crisis and even through the the first
year and a half of that recovery this
time around you're seeing business
formation applications Skyrocket they're
up 25% year-over-year and again it's
creative destruction this is AB Bess
very well for the next couple of years
of economic growth the last difference
in the two cycles is really from a
demographic perspective and one of the
most underrated reasons of why you saw
slow growth during the last decade was
from demographics and those headwinds
were coming from two distinct areas on
the right hand side of the chart you saw
a huge increase of baby boomers that
were exiting the workforce a huge
increase that the US economy has never
seen before and as people retire they
spend and earn less that's a headwind to
economic growth but also in the middle
of the chart there you can see that
Boomers exiting their Prime spending and
earnings years which happens to be ages
35 through 54 in the US they were being
replaced by a much smaller Gen X which
means smaller fewer individuals entering
into those Prime spending and earnings
years you fast forward to today instead
of having a demographic headwind you
have a demographic tailwind and it's
really similar to 1994 now in the middle
of the chart there you can see that
Millennials entering into their Peak
years is going to be a Tailwind to
economic growth in the US well into the
next decade really over the next 15
years you have more and more Millennials
spending and earning more um but the
demographic Tailwind is going to be less
than what we saw in 1994 because if you
look on the right hand side of the chart
you have a lot more baby boomers heading
into retirement today versus what you
saw about 25 years ago so taking a step
back and talking you know about you know
what the core conclusion is here is that
this is a very different setup than what
we had coming out of the global
financial crisis is a different cause of
the recession you don't have any
economic overhangs like you had back in
the global financial crisis the policy
prescription was right so you had less
economic scarring
households are in a very strong position
to continue spending labor markets are
in a very good position today um also
you have broad-based confidence and
demographics are going to be helpful to
economic growth and this all is in a
backdrop when the FED is not going to
take the punch bow away from the party
and they're going to remain very
accommodative well into this recovery
which is not the traditional experience
that we've seen now one thing I'll
mention is there's a lot of people that
are concerned about valuations at the
moment uh with the forward P of the
market at 2 2.5 you've only seen this
eclipsed back in during the dot bubble
um but one thing I want to mention here
is you you can't look at valuations in
isolation valuations today should be
different than what you see valuations
in 1980 versus 1950 and the reason why I
say that is for a number of different
reasons first off the index composition
of the S&P 500 has been different over
the last hundred years and in order to
illustrate this what we did is we looked
at all the cyclical areas of the market
which are financials Industrials
materials and energy we've bracketed
them together and that's the dark gray
line that you see in front of you and
then we bracketed all your growth
stability and defensive sectors together
which is the Blue Line there and and
traditionally cyclical sectors are
awarded lower PE multiples because they
have huge swings in their earnings
potential based on economic activity um
and your growth stability and defensive
areas of the market are usually awarded
higher pees because they usually have a
high degree of earnings visibility they
have Moes around their business or
they're growing much faster than the
index overall and as of today cyclical
representation of the S&P 500 is at a
100-year low at 23% so the average p PE
of the market has been 16 given this
less Cy cyclical representation in the
S&P 500 maybe it should be a couple of
turns higher the other reason why
valuations should probably be higher
today versus history is because interest
rates are low and in fact as of the end
of the year 49% of the S&P 500 had a
dividend yield greater than a 30-year
treasury um so if you think about
interest rates one of the key components
of valuating uh stocks and the earnings
of a stock is interest rates and if you
have a lower discount rate all things
considered you should have a higher P
multiple to pay for that dollar of
earnings the other thing that I'll
mention right now is usually at this
point in the cycle stocks look expensive
because as you come off of recessionary
troughs usually PE multiple Skyrocket as
the market anticipates future earnings
growth and the Market grows into that
earnings expectation so if you look at
the off of the trough of the tech bubble
and the global financial crisis almost
the entirety of the S&P 500 returns
during those first five nine months was
from pees expanding but as you move to
the 12 months following that point and
the 12 months following that point so
the next couple of years the Baton hands
off two earnings and they really Drive
um the market forward uh in those
subsequent years and you actually see PE
multiples decline in years two and
following a earnings an economic trough
putting this all together how stretch
your out evaluations well the historic
PE is 16 you take sector mixed impact
into consideration the lack of
cyclicality maybe historic earnings
should be one turn higher versus history
you take low interest rate rates into
consideration should be two turns higher
versus history considering the robust
earnings backdrop that we have in 2021
and 2022 one and a half turns higher
than that and then in that other bucket
that's a a number of different uh
considerations free cash flow generation
is much higher versus history you have
higher margins as well and this also is
a over undervaluation versus what fair
value should be so if you put this whole
waterfall together uh at forward PE at
22.5 today maybe 21.5 is fair value
given all these dynamics that we talked
about so this isn't the.com bubble 2.0
there's a key reason why you have
valuations at these current levels and
again given our above consensus
expectations for economic growth we
think earnings could surprise to the
upside next year the last thing I'll
mention here is usually um if markets
have moved a long way off of the trough
a lot of people think that there isn't
more upside for the S&P 500 but this is
not the way that we're thinking about
things in fact we do think that the S&P
500 has a lot more upside uh for the
rest of this expansion um so we looked
at the S&P 500 from the start of every
economic expansion since 1970 and what
it returned to the start of the next
recession we're not looking at the
market trough which happened to be March
23rd but the start of the economic
expansion which we don't know yet
because the NBR has not designated when
the recession ended but from our
estimation we think it's probably going
to be June so this is looking at it
really from July 1st through the end of
this expansion and if you look at that
blue area there the average move higher
in the S&P 500 is 96% but if you look
right below that the average move higher
in a secular bull market is 149% and one
of our core views and it's that we are
clearly in a secular bull market in the
US and if you're not familiar with the
term usually us financial markets go
through a 10 to 20 year period where
they go nowhere that's better known as a
secular bare market and they're followed
by a 20year period where the markets go
up substantially better known as a
secular bull market so in the 30s and
40s on the lefthand side you can see
there's a pretty substantial secular
bare market during those two decades
your cumulative return was negative 22%
but that g gave rise to the secular Bull
of the 50s and 60s return jumped up to
450% of course that gave rise to the
secular bear of the 70s with high
inflation returns were roughly flat
followed by the secular Bull of the 80s
and 90s return jumped up to 1,50% and
it's our view and it continues to be our
view that we exited the secular bear of
the 2000s we're now in year 11 of 20
where you're going to see outsize Equity
returns obviously doesn't mean you're
going to aren't going to have bumps on
the road or recessions because we
clearly just had one but if this trend
continues which has been going on for
the last 90 years there's going to be a
lot more upside for us equities as we
move through this decade and everybody
always asks what's going to propel this
secular bull market higher um I think
it's clear that this is a different
recovery and the FED is not going to get
in the way of that recovery in the near-
term so it's going to be really good for
risk assets also I think there's a clear
difference that the Baton has moved uh
handed off from monetary policy to
fiscal policy if you think back to the
last recovery um you even though
monetary policy was very aggressive um
fiscal policy was a little bit more
restrictive there was a lot of austerity
measures this time around both fiscal
policy monetary policy are rowing in the
same directions uh which is going to be
a powerful force and then lastly I think
you're going to see a lot of investors
move towards dividend paying equities
for income and growth of income uh in
this low rate environment um so you know
maybe to sum everything up um even
though the markets have moved a long way
off of the lows we do think that there's
some more upside from here valuations
look expensive but if you take low
interest rates into consideration sector
mix and the expectations for strong
earnings over the next couple of years I
think these valuations are Justified um
and then also um I think economic growth
is really going to surprise on the
upside because of all those differences
that we talked about with the global
financial crisis but also consumers will
likely have2 trillion dollar in excess
savings to be able to fuel that recovery
over the next couple of years um so with
that maybe I can turn it back to uh um
to the audience to see if you guys have
any
questions thank you Jeff that was very
stimulating a lot of good
information um now we're going to get a
get to be able to use these charts I
hope my question is
this what our biggest source of Revenue
in the state comes from business
taxes and so that and we have to project
revenues out for a two-year period
starting July 1
2021 what would you say that the GDP or
the growth of U businesses will be on
average over these two two years
starting July 1
yeah I think U most businesses that have
were going to go out of business
probably will uh over the next six
months um but again I think given the
business formation Trends um I think
you're going to see an acceleration of
of of number of businesses that uh that
are going to be in the state but also
the amount of Revenue that you're going
to see um and given the expectation for
above Trend growth uh you know 6% real
GDP growth is probably closer to 8%
nominal GDP growth um I would expect a
huge bump in in and business taxes over
the next couple of years um somewhere in
the tune of you know call it six to
eight% All Things
Considered
urle um thank you Mr chair I've got
several questions actually but uh let's
begin with the ones you you uh talked
about one of the driving forces of the
economic growth over the last uh decade
has been weaker energy costs and uh a
stable wage
environment if the government starts to
play with these things either the
federal or state level what would be the
effect you've got a crystal ball in
front of you so you just have to ask it
and get the answer right away what would
be the effect on uh our economy would it
go up would it go down would it remain
the same you know that kind of
thing yes so one of the the the um
obviously the the key tendance of
Biden's agenda is higher minimum wage of
going to $15 um that would obviously be
cumulative for on a state level for
payroll taxes um but and from a federal
level from payroll taxes um it would
also bring down you know obviously the
bottom line for for a lot of small
businesses I say the net effect is
probably neutral um it's just you know
it's going to be labor that gains more
share versus capital in that instance um
so I don't necessarily see a big
difference there um also as far as wage
growth is concerned if you aren't able
to pass a higher minimum wage tax I I
see wage growth remaining relatively
stable over the next couple of years
because the unemployment rates at 6.7%
which means there's still quite a bit of
slack left in the US economy usually
you'll start to see wage growth
percolate higher when that gets closer
to 5% um so again um I don't see a huge
Effect one way or another um with that
higher minimum wage if it does go into
effect at a federal level um and then
your other question was minimum wage and
then if I forget the other half energy
energy yeah so there's a lot of Supply
out there on with the energy on on the
energy front um even if you do see
restrictions on being able to Frack on
federal lands um Shale producers right
now are really just trying to generate
free cash flow rather than growth at all
costs which is a key difference from the
model that they had really through the
beginning part of that last deck G
through the
2016 um also the global Supply there's a
a lot of oil out there right now um and
you're going to have a until you can get
to a full um global economy um to be
able to get back to normalized levels of
demand which is around 100 million
barrels per day you're going to continue
to see energy costs kind of languish
here in the the 50 or $60 range um you
really got to see a return of air travel
uh to get back to normalization before
you could see energy costs at 70 or $80
a barrel because uh jet fuel accounts
for about 7% of global uh en uh Global
oil demand All Things Considered so um I
don't see you know anything changing on
the energy front I think oil is going to
be pretty well pinned in this 50 to to
$55 Barrel range over the next couple of
years regardless of regulations and you
know some U regulations on frackers here
in the US follow up Mr chair um just one
because we have about eight more people
to ask
questions I saw that and the followup is
uh you also talked about a growing
savings uh um with that's common folk uh
1 Point uh five trillion heading towards
two trillion you
anticipated um do you believe that uh
there will be an attempt by the
government to attempt to recoup some of
that money for their own
coffers I don't I don't um I think it'
be very difficult to to be able to to do
that uh especially you know if you look
at governmental actions here recently um
you know you had that $600 stimulus
check that went out in December um
there's talk of making that another
$1,400 stimulus check um so they're
clearly seeing the savings rate but they
do recognize ize that there's a lot of
lower and middle inome individuals and
households that are going to need those
checks in order to get through the first
and second quarter until you can get to
some some sort of normalization so I I
actually don't see a situation where the
the government will try to recoup that
money thank
you representative
Ames thank you um and thank you for the
presentation it was really excellent
encourage encouraging I would say uh
the Assumption in there or at least one
of the points you made was that uh that
we'd reach her
immunity sometime in the second half
early part of the second half of uh of
this year as I understood it um and I've
seen other forecasts on that score that
put it out another year actually um and
so my question really is uh what
difference does that make to your
forecast suppose suppose uh the supply
of vaccinations doesn't gear up uh the
uh the other snags whatever in the
vaccination process and uh we don't come
to her immunity until mid
2022 uh what then yeah ratchet my
economic growth expectation down
dramatically um you're going to see a
lot more pain in the services a lot more
bankruptcies um but I would anticipate
if that was indeed the case um that you
probably have more stimulus coming out
of Washington over the course of 2021 to
be able to stem the tide until we can
get to her immunity um but uh you know
from all the projections that that I've
uh looked at here recently um I would
imagine at the latest her immunity
coming in at the end of the third
quarter I think one of the bigger
obstacles is you know giving the
American public uh some people have some
reluctance uh on taking a vaccine given
the quick timeline that these have been
coming out versus you know the
traditional five or 10 years that you've
seen from a vaccine perspective um but
you know as long as the vaccines that
are in commercialization come to
commercialization and what I'm really
looking for is Johnson and Johnson's
advocacy data um if Johnson and Johnson
can get through uh the the FDA the
hurdles of coming to commercialization
um I I think her immunity will be
reached sometime in the third quarter
because they're they're going to be the
the one that could bring the most doses
online not only for the us but for the
global
Ronnie thank you uh great presentation I
just want to follow up on Jordan's
question a little bit more um let's talk
about a few other issues that may change
uh things philosophies that may change
number one regulation on business but
two more importantly is the tax tax Pol
tax increases potentially Jolie
especially business tax uh increases in
areas that have
incentivized companies to come back to
America um can you just touch on that a
little
bit yeah obviously to to be able to pay
for the most recent stimulus package
taxes are going to to have to rise I do
think businesses will bear the brunt of
that um I I I would imagine the
corporate tax rate moving back up to 25
26% from 21% currently um you can see
higher taxes on on cap gains um I could
see that going up to 25 26% as well um I
think the top income bracket will move
back to where it was prior to the Trump
tax cuts at
39.6% um but again I think those are
really going to be the the only key
taxes that come into play here um I know
the headline number for the new stimulus
package is 1.9 trillion um I think that
number is going to come drastically down
um probably into the1 trillion dollar
range um and uh you know again the key
here is given the fact that the US
economy is in a precarious position here
you're seeing a deceleration of Labor
Market activity um I think these tax
increases probably come into effect in
20122 because uh obviously you don't
want to derail the budding recovery that
we have right now um so overall I I do
see higher taxes um I do see higher
taxes especially for uh a lot of your
companies that have overseas tax
shelters um I I think you know big tech
for example is going to see much higher
taxes um but overall um still
corporations are in a better position
today even with these tax increases than
when they were uh going into the Trump
tax cuts that happened back in 2017 so
net net obviously it'll be reflected on
uh the financial markets you could see
markets go down about five or 7% to
price in this new tax reality um but uh
again given the robust economic backdrop
that I've outlined here I think
businesses are going to be able to
overcome this momentary increase of of
their tax liability and they their
pressure on their their margin
structure uh representative
southw thank you great uh presentation I
wondered um are there things that you
really feel are specific or unique to
New Hampshire it seemed like last time
we were one of the last New England
states to kind of bounce
back yeah you guys are number one one of
the number one drivers of the economy is
smart manufacturing um I think that's
going to be a theme uh throughout the
course of the next decade I I think New
Hampshire is well positioned on that
front as well um so you know I think you
guys are well positioned to to be able
to thrive over the next decade um
because of that core competency and that
leadership that you have um that that's
one of the things that that we looked at
um prior to the call and I think it's
going to be a key differentiator for
jenin thank you Mr chairman um nice
presentation Jeffrey very informative um
just to build on representative Abram's
uh questions I had the same questions
but I guess when you talked about the
next decade being pretty strong I'm
assuming you've
already uh put in the fact that you
believe taxes will be higher regulations
will be more intense so when you talk
about that you you're already planning
for that yes yeah okay thank you
thank you um I'm wondering about
something fairly different on the
business taxes are our biggest taxes but
on we have a wide range of other
consumption taxes in this state uh that
affect mostly the middle class and how
far down does ownership of these savings
go at this point in the in the structure
bifurcated economy it's a great question
and I think you've hit the the on the
head for most of the stimulus package
that come out um lower income households
have spent a majority of those uh the
fiscal stimulus that has come out um
middle class has saved uh you know more
than the the lower income hoses but it's
really the the top death that has saved
the most um but nonetheless given this
fact that you have you know roughly
$2,000 going to each American that's
qualifies uh over the course of the the
next year if assuming that the package
that's been forth put out with the
Democrats goes into effect um that's
going to go a long way to to Really
juicing up the savings rate for low and
middle inome houses so I I think you're
going to see a boom in in your uh your
state regardless uh even if it is more
middle income than than lower or
high
Senator
guer Bob you have to unmute Bob you need
to unmute yourself okay there we go
thank you Mr chairman
um from the from the point of view of
prognostication would it be appropriate
to say that we could be moderately
conservative for the first of the two
fiscal years for which we're preparing a
budget and somewhat more more for lack
of a better word exuberant or certainly
positive as far as revenues to the state
in the second year of the
bium well I I I I think it all comes
down to you know how how much economic
retrenchment you see over the course of
the first and second quarter here right
um if you continue to see the virus case
load increase um which we gotten through
the holiday season I would imagine that
you're starting to see a plateau of
cases and they'll start to come down and
economic activity starts to accelerate
meaningfully at the end of the first
quarter which is my expectation um I
think you know you you don't necessarily
have to be more prudent year one versus
year two um but if you do see cases
continue to increase you know post
holidays as we get into February and
March um again that that may be a better
way to approach it but I would I just
based on my expectation right now I
think both years are going to be very
strong economically speaking and I don't
necessarily think that you have to be
more prudent year one versus your year
two at this
point
Tucker took my hand down all right then
representative
Baxter thank you Mr chair and thank you
Jeffrey for your presentation I just
want to follow up on your comment about
the minimum wage and it being neutral
for the economy the CBO released a
report about six months ago saying a $15
minimum minimum wage would cost CA about
3.7 million job losses so especially in
New Hampshire where 90 plus% of the
employers are small businesses isn't it
more likely that's going to have a more
negative effect in New
Hampshire Well yeah if 90% of the the
businesses are small businesses in the
state yeah I think that would probably
be net negative but again I I think
given the fact that you do have so many
job openings out there at this given
moment this early on in the recovery
even if you do see job losses that are
substantial with your lower income
individuals I I think that they be able
to simulate very quickly back into the
labor force uh given the fact that there
is quite a bit of slack there but there
also is a very large need uh for labor
at this given moment but yes I I would
imagine if you go to $15 minimum wage
you're going to see Automation in a lot
of uh you know small businesses where
you can do that which would eliminate a
lot of those uh the lower paying jobs
that are out there but net net I do
think that you would see a rebound in
the labor market fairly quickly should
that come to
fruition thanks for your
feedback
okay representative southw you have your
Aly uh I'm sorry but I think that our
hands didn't get taken
questions I don't I don't see any
further questions I mean uh this has
been a perfect presentation for what we
need at this point in time you brought
in the mix of the effect of the pandemic
which is a big
unknown I you told us
that if it's looking like the injections
are going to happen and what happens if
if we meet a million a day and what
that'll do with the economy and you've
given us an idea what if it doesn't do
that so we appreciate that so there's
been no further questions we thank you
very much thank you for having me on
yeah all right represented major there
is a hand up on the attendee side I
didn't know if you wanted to few minutes
I'm sorry
that the uh can you bring that up for me
Jen because I don't see
G morning uh Norm this is uh Joe yeah
okay go ahead
you uh Jeffrey I want to thank you uh
for uh helping us in this situation
ation I did have one question um there
recently there's been a move in the in
the price of the 10 year treasury so you
know the the yield bottomed in uh the
spring um and then you know around 50
basis points and then in August started
to move from the low 50s and now we're
up at about um you know 1.10% on the
10year uh and obviously that has an
effect on um you know business's
borrowing costs and also mortgages etc
etc can you talk about um
the you know that phenomena how that
might affect um you know the economy and
also um the fed's um you know inability
to to uh you know control the uh Broad
water Bond markets please yeah a great
great question Joe so um obviously the
tenure has moved up 60 basis points
roughly from the lows um but if you
think about other recessionary troughs
and the recoveries that have happened
10year treasury use usually moves up
closer to one and a half to 2% so even
though 60 basis points is you know
double from where we were back in April
for example it's still low relative to
history and usually Rising long rates or
Rising 10e treasuries will have a bite
on iomic activity around 12 to 18 months
later um so it's one of the key reasons
why I think not only 2021 will be strong
but 2022 will be strong because again at
only a rise of 60 basis points that's
very moderate compared to what you've
seen versus history now if you're going
to have GDP growth you know real GDP
growth at 6% this year real GDP growth
next year being close to four and a half
or or maybe even five um I think that
the tenear treasury will start to creep
higher over the course of this year um
but you're not really going to feel the
economic effects of that really until
the middle part of 2022 maybe until the
later part of that year as well but uh
again um it's very low compared to
history uh tene treasuries are one of
the the biggest drivers of economic
activity and again this is one of the
again one of the core reasons why I'm
I'm fairly optimistic over the LA next
couple of years and speaking about the
FED uh and the response function one of
the key reasons why the 10year treasury
hasn't moved higher is because they
moved to that average inflation
targeting regime um signaling that
they're not intending to raise rates
over the next three or four years um so
you know that's kind of tethering the
10e down to these lower levels um but I
think as you see the the recovery unfold
here um and it does come in more strong
than consensus expectations I would
imagine that the tenure treasury is
going to continue to melt higher over
the course of this year reaching maybe
one and a half
1.75% by the end of 2021 but again with
that lag the fact you're really not
going to start to feel that economic
bite until a year or year and a half
later and and and one one thing I'll
mention Joe is that the FED can tweak
their QE purchases if they wanted to
right now um you know they're doing 120
billion per month 80 of which are
treasury purchases um if the 10e
treasury starts to rise dramatically
from here uh and it's it's getting a
little disorderly similar to the taper
tantrum that you saw in
2013 the FED can tweak the composition
of those purchases to buy longer data
treasuries dur in the 10-year and trying
to to cap that and keep them lower I
don't think there's any real reason for
them to do that at this point as long as
the tene treasury rises in an orderly
fashion um and you don't see a taper
tantrum um I think the FED will keep
their asset purchases consistent with
what they've been doing recently but
again if it does start to move higher um
and it's uh getting to the point where
they're getting concerned that there is
some concerns about debt issuance and
the digestion of the all the debt that's
coming to the market this year um they
probably will tweak that composition to
keep long longer rates lower for longer
to help the economy and keep it
stimulative over the next couple of
years okay I want to say something here
Joe uh gimmel is a vice president of
Morgan Stanley and he's been my
financial advisor for quite a while and
it was Joe that was able to get Jeff to
come in and make this presentation to us
I want to thank Joe as well as Jeff
thank you thank you so any further
questions if not then we'll close this
session and be on time to open the next
one and thanks Jeff uh and Joe
appreciate
it Ben 10
o' our next presenter is Phil
Phil is a senior policy Analyst at
the New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute an independent nonprofit
policy research organization based in
conord Phill researches New Hampshire
budget and revenue policy the economy
and how it relates to the financial
well-being of the state's
residents and the health policy here is
a New Hampshire native who previously
served as a performance audit auditor
for the New Hampshire office the
legislative budget assistant so Phil
it's yours for the next
hour thank you very much chairman major
thank you for the opportunity uh to
speak to you uh this morning and thank
you to representatives and senators of
the ways and means committees um so I
want to I'm going to share my screen if
I have permission to do that which it
appears I do thank you to Jen um and I
screen can I get an acknowledgement
everyone can see my screen I
hope yes okay great thank you very much
um so I want to talk to you today a
little bit about New Hampshire's economy
um how New Hampshire's economy is
interacting with household finances and
has in the past particularly looking at
some of that uh economic recovery from
the uh last recession from the Great
Recession of 2007 to 2009 and what those
might mean for state revenues as well
and I should say um if there are
technical questions about particular
slides I'm happy to either uh take them
or as the over the course of the
presentation or go back to them um at
the end of the presentation of J major
I'll I'll leave that up to you but I'm
happy to be interrupted if there's um if
there's a burning question about a
particular
slide um why don't we try that and if it
slowes now we'll have to wait till the
end of your presentation okay that's no
problem what whatever way um you believe
works best um so just to talk a little
bit about the shock that we saw the
initial impact of the covid-19 crisis um
this graph shows New Hampshire's Gross
State product so when we think about the
national economy you might think of
gross domestic product or GDP this is
scaled down to the state level what is
the Gross State product and this is
these are annualized numbers as well so
this is not this is if the economy was
the size that it was in each quarter
which is how the Bureau of economic
analysis reports it and these are
inflation adjusted numbers as well so
you can see this graph shows uh the
third quarter of 2010 to the third
quarter of 2020 and that uh that second
quarter of 2020 where we saw that sort
of initial impact of the pandemic that
the size of the economy in that quarter
was about the same that it was in early
2014 so obviously a major setback in
terms of economic growth in the state
however we did see a rebound in uh the
third quarter of 2020 a very substantial
Rebound in terms of the overall size of
the economy still back to about 2017
levels um these data will probably be
revised over time but I wanted to give
you a sense of you know in terms of the
total size of the economy What do the
impact looked like and it was even a
more dramatic impact in New Hampshire as
it was around the country on employment
and I know you heard some from New
Hampshire employment security yesterday
um they dove into these numbers more
than I will but I wanted to provide a
little bit of context relative to what
we saw in the Great Recession um of 2007
to 2009 you can see this graph goes back
to 2006 and it's uh the recession is
shaded
there uh the a number of employed
residents in New Hampshire estimated
through these surveys uh did drop
relative significantly during the Great
Recession which of course was a major
economic event uh but if you continue to
follow that orange line you can see that
between the March survey and the April
survey the estimated number of New
Hampshire residents employed dropped by
a little over 15,000 people and that's
very significant including especially
given that we're talking about roughly
750,000 people employed uh who are
residents of the state now of course
there has been a fair bit of recovery um
there's been a pretty pretty dramatic
recovery really beating expectations uh
that a lot of folks had early on in the
crisis um and uh and that is a positive
sign I would do want to flag the
civilian labor force line as well that
blue line that we see here that's
counting the people who are employed or
or who are looking for work who are
unemployed but looking for work as
defined um by the Bureau of Labor
Statistics and uh here we can see that
the civilian labor force has dropped
people have taken themselves out of the
out of the economy and out of the labor
force um and that number hasn't
increased as quickly we have yet to see
those uh December numbers for New
Hampshire um that may tell us a little
bit more um we saw there was a um uh in
terms of the total number of people
employed there was a tick down in those
December numbers nationally we don't
know what um at least I don't know yet
what the New Hampshire numbers are for
are at this point maybe New Hampshire
employment security offered you some
insight there yesterday um but you can
see that that civilian labor force
number it if that if that stays lower or
if that takes a longer time to recover
that does have some implications for the
economy that's likely because there are
a lot of folks who are you know staying
home to either avoid the virus
themselves or to take care of children
or older adults who might otherwise be
um be in a different setting and be
cared for in a different setting but
because of the pandemic they haven't
been able to be um or I I think there
may be some folks who are um who were
engaged in the labor force who lost
employment and who were either near or
couple years into what they considered
retirement age maybe they're lucky
enough that they have the assets
available to be able to retire so there
are questions in my mind around how many
of those people come back or how many
have uh um uh taken you know this time
this job loss as uh as the transition to
retirement if you will because we have a
fair number of people in New Hampshire
who are in that sort of age bracket
where that's a choice they may be making
now I do want to note that the shock to
employment that we see here is not has
not been evenly distributed across wage
groups so these are data that are um
that are based on private sector high
frequency data um that looking at jobs
and particular jobs by wages and these
are data that are crunched by um
researchers at Harvard and brown
universities and um they are in this
graph comparing what was employment in
high middle and low wage work in uh New
Hampshire in January relative to what it
is the graph goes through um um about
mid- October and here you can see that
high wage work which is that reddish
line um High wage work did dip
significantly but recovered by the time
we got to about late spring early summer
um and appears to be running a little
bit higher in terms of the number of
jobs that are high wage jobs available
uh middle wage work we could see had a
larger dip and a much longer recovery
timeline and low wage work is still down
about 20% and uh that suggests that
people who were working in for examp
example a low-wage job or working
several low-wage jobs before the
pandemic so back in January some of
those folks may have moved to a middle
or high wage job but many of them are
probably still looking for either one uh
low-wage job or a supplementary low-wage
job and they're not finding as many
opportunities because of what we see in
terms of what's what jobs are available
for them to enter into so that these
data anyway suggests that the the
economic impacts have been really uneven
in terms of um who's able to find
employment and who's able to earn income
from employment and we see that a little
bit as well in New Hampshire employment
security data they've done an excellent
job crunching numbers for us on a on a
weekly basis um and Publishing them in
terms of uh where unemployment claims
have been have come from on an industry
by industry basis and this graph shows
you the initial claims so that total
volume of initial claims this isn't you
know necessarily continuing claims so
these don't always uh represent what's
happening in these industries now but
these initial claims are in those green
bars those these show the six highest in
initial claims totals by industry by
industry pardon me and the orange bars
beside it show the average weekly wage
in these industries that were paid in
2019 and uh the the line across the
middle is the average weekly wage um for
all uh all workers in 2019 in New
Hampshire and here you can see that um
all the way over on the left Food
Services and drinking places has a very
high a number of initial claims much
higher than any other industry and also
a relatively low wage again these are
wages reported um through um New
Hampshire Employment Securities uh um
census of employed workers um so these
um uh covered employment wages pardon me
um it's called something different at
the federal level um so that industry is
an example of where we've probably seen
a lot of people who were previously um
low-wage workers
who are um uh who are still looking for
work or unable to find work uh social
assistance is another area where we see
you know fairly low wages and a fairly
large number of job losses um there are
some other uh there are some other ones
here as well um that offer somewhat
higher wages but here are the industries
that we've seen the biggest impacts and
this has these impacts have had a fairly
significant impact especially on low
wage and low asset um households uh we
can see that um if we if we look at a
survey that's conducted by the US Census
Bureau it's called the household pulse
survey it's conducted in every state the
survey has changed a little bit over
time but as of the last survey that
asked the question um which was in mid
July close to half of households in New
Hampshire had lost employment income
between March 13th and mid July that's a
very significant swath of households
that lost some form of employment income
that they would have been expecting
potentially over that time period about
one in three households looking at the
most recent survey data or the mid
December survey data about one in three
households in in New Hampshire indicated
it had been somewhat or very difficult
to pay for usual household expenses
during the prior seven days now we don't
have data that mirrors that exactly from
the pre-pandemic uh era the household
pulse survey is something that's
happened only in 2020 and and sort of
post the pandemic um impacting uh
people's finances but um we do some
similar data that shows uh that asks a
similar question that I'll get to a
little bit later um but shows that it's
likely a lower number um a sign a
substantially lower number and again
this is December this is not April and
May when we saw those highest um the
least amount of jobs um about a quarter
of respondents expected a loss of
household employment income in the next
four weeks and again that's of mid
December so that may um Express that may
show some anxiety around heading into
the winter months and uh losing some of
those employment opportunities are are
dependent in part on out being outside
and then 11% of households indicated
they sometimes are often did not have
enough food to eat in the prior seven
days so again suggesting that family
budgets are being squeezed uh in a way
that does harm their ability to be food
secure so those are uh those numbers all
suggest that there's been a pretty
profound impact especially again at the
low end of the income Spectrum we see
that in Medicaid enrollment in New
Hampshire as well Medicaid of course as
a state federal fiscal partnership uh
program that helps provide or helps
people with low incomes and limited
means generally access health coverage
and health health care and here we can
see that enrollment has increased
relatively significantly in New
Hampshire was declining as the economy
was improving over the course of 2019 we
get to the end of February and there
were about 179,000 people enrolled in
New Hampshire and but as of the end of
December the most recent numbers we have
it's gone up a little under 19% in terms
of the total number of people who are
enrolled in Medicaid now there are
certain eligibility criteria for
Medicaid uh the federal government has
as as part of their um part of one of
their earlier Aid packages has required
that people not be disenrolled from
Medicaid even if they are no longer
income eligible um however we've seen
this number continue to climb and there
was a little there was some research
done uh earlier in the pandemic in
Minnesota uh around how many people are
enrolled in Medicaid because they are
continuously income eligible or still
income eligible versus how many people
are were income eligible enrolled and
would no longer be income eligible in
normal circumstances if you will and
they found that actually was a pretty
small percentage were the portion who uh
were income eligible at one point and
were still enrolled in the program even
though they wouldn't be in under normal
policy if you will so that suggests that
a lot of this I mean obviously that's
Minnesota and earlier in the pandemic
but that suggest that a lot of this is
is it's probably a lot of people who
were near the income eligibility
threshold before and had but had
employment income that they no longer
have now um of course that's a program
that helps uh make people more
financially secure Medicaid is we've
seen a lot of federal action that has
really provided a very significant very
important income boost to the economy U
during um uh during calendar year 2020
so here this graph shows uh personal
income from different sources from
different sort of categories of sources
and I provided the first the four
quarters of 2019 to sort of give you
context as to what these swings look
like you can see in the second quarter
of 2020 the green bar which shows those
net earnings from work dropped quite
significantly uh but there were in that
orange bar transfer payments that really
did boost um uh Inc personal incomes and
those transfer payments uh are include
the federal enhanced unemployment comp
compensation benefits um the direct Aid
to individuals and for example those
$1,200 checks that were to provide
relief to individuals those uh likely
pushed that number positive very
positive relative to the prior quarter
um in the second quarter of 2020 in the
third quarter of 2020 we see that net
earnings from work did rebound it didn't
get quite back up to the levels that
were lost in the prior quarter but it
did increase um so there are probably a
fair number of low- wage jobs that are
that are included in that uh in that gap
between the drop that we see and the
increase that we see in uh the third
quarter um but we also see that transfer
payments folded back a very significant
amount from the prior quarter and again
that indicates that a lot of those um a
lot of those Federal actions were
designed to be temporary or were time
limited and That Was Then support the
economy didn't have going into the
second half of 2020 again these numbers
do change they are revised um and we'll
see what the fourth quarter of 2020
looks like but that boost to economic
activity or that boost to resources
available to people in the economy uh is
uh is important action on the federal
side um and uh and is a difference from
some of the things that we saw prior to
the um during the recovery from the
Great Recession and let's go back and
look at that a little bit and where New
Hampshire sits in that recovery from the
Great Recession the prior conversation
there was a little bit noted about this
um so this graph shows the total gross
domestic product or gross State product
um at at the state level of the United
States as a whole in Green New Hampshire
in Orange and labeled you can see the
individual years of growth labeled and
then the remainder of the New England
states in blue and this is all pegged to
2005 so and inflation adjusted so it
shows the relative size of the economy
and you can see that New Hampshire
actually took a little while to grow uh
coming out to have faster economic
growth coming out of the last recession
it lagged a little bit behind new its
New England neighbors and still is a
little bit behind where the United
States is it wasn't really until 2014
2015 2016 that we saw that growth pick
up so again it was a delayed recovery
and particularly a delayed recovery in
New Hampshire but the size of the
economy was overall larger when you get
to the 2017 2018 2019 certainly um in
inflation adjusted terms the economy was
bigger in New Hampshire than it was
prior to the pandemic prior to Pardon Me
The Great Recession um but that wasn't
true for everyone's wages um this graph
shows the desiles really percentiles of
uh different parts of the wage Spectrum
in New Hampshire so the median wage is
at that 50th percentile and you can see
the dollar figure from the 2017 to 2019
data is about 20 half dollars an hour uh
that um uh this shows the higher wages
so for example the 90th percentile only
10% of the wages are higher than than
that the 10th percentile only 10% of the
wages are lower than that this graph
compares the inflation adjusted 2004 to
2006 wages to the 2017 to 2019 wages and
this shows that again people with middle
people had consistently had middle wages
or lower wages didn't see much growth in
real purchasing power was about flat um
in terms of real purchasing power across
that portion of the wage Spectrum even
if you even after the longest uh e the
longest period of economic growth that
we have that we've calculated in US
history calculations go back to the
1850s um based on the national Bure of
economic research so that suggests that
there were a lot of people who weren't
able to contribute as much to the
economic growth that we were seeing
because their purchasing power was lower
than it was um prior to the Great
Recession um or only on par with it and
if you take these same data and break it
out by year it shows how many people
especially again uh lower wage earners
and middle wage earners had years during
the economic recovery where their
purchasing power was diminished over
time and that likely slowed the economic
recovery obviously there's some
interaction between what we see in sort
of the Topline numbers and what we see
when we dig down into these numbers but
um but that likely slowed the economic
recovery consumers are you know 67% of
uh of all economic expenditures come
from personal consumption so if fewer
people have the resources available to
afford um buying goods and services that
slows the economy because that means
there's less there's less purchasing
power among more people in that um in
that important part of the P so again
you can see here in green um the figures
falling well below that 100 line which
is those inflation adjusted wages again
pegged to 2005 it wasn't until really in
New Hampshire we saw the under 3% um
unemployment rate uh really putting
pressure on the labor market or or boo
helping boost wages uh to get to that
2017 2018 2019 boost that got people you
know back to about where they were in
2005 and 2006 um but uh again that's
after a long period of economic recovery
and these wage boosts that we saw in the
low end of the income Spectrum um
there's probably some interaction as
well with another measure of household
well-being which is food insecurity um
these data come in a little bit of a
slower pace and we have to look at
threeyear averages to have enough data
to know what's going on in New Hampshire
but here you can see the United States
uh in Green New England in blue and New
Hampshire in Orange and this is again
looking at that overall food insecurity
rate New Hampshire's is lower which is
great news it's excellent that we have
lower food insecurity um than the United
States as a whole um that being said if
you start to look at about 2011 in 2012
you see that the food insecurity rate in
the United States as a whole started
dropping and started Dr dropping in a
steady fashion um again as part of the
economic recovery um but in New
Hampshire it didn't really start
dropping in a in a way that we could say
is statistically significant anyway
until you get to 2016 and Beyond and
looking at those sort of 2016 and Beyond
data and that corresponds with what we
saw at the low end of the wage Spectrum
so um again when we're talking about um
wages at the uh wages at the low end of
the income Spectrum in the middle of the
income Spectrum the sort of cascading
effects in terms of how households will
being in ability to afford goods and
services in the economy now looking at a
different data set that sort of um shows
the trends in another way this is median
household income with that orange
showing the inflation adjustment to the
most recent dollars the 2019 dollars
median household income in New Hampshire
you can see that it was climbing prior
to the Great Recession so we get to 2007
there's that sort of earlier Peak and
then there was a drop off and it took
until again we saw that sort of faster
economic growth
really after 2014 and into 2015 and 2016
um where we saw median house gold income
sort of bump back up and get back to
those pre uh recession levels and even
start to in 2019 exceed them a little
bit but again um it's not hasn't been a
continuous path and there was a period
where a lot of people had less real
purchasing power again that probably
slowed the economic
recovery now um thinking about the
industry makeup thinking about where
some of these jobs have been lost and
where people have been earning income
in New Hampshire um there have been
there are some large industries that
have lower wages that are important
Employers in New Hampshire and this is
important when we're thinking about
which Industries are going to come back
which Industries have been most affected
which Industries are um likely to help
the economic recovery the most or maybe
lag behind the most and here you can see
in Orange is in the lighter orange is
retail trade and in the darker orange or
is accommodation in Food Services again
industries that have lower average
weekly wages
and um and those are important industry
sectors in the economy in New Hampshire
and these are again employment by 20 in
2019 Healthcare and social assistance is
the largest employer for a long time it
had been retail and Healthcare and
social assistance recently passed it
that Healthcare and social assistance
obviously includes a very wide range of
um of wages depending on the job that
someone is doing there's some very high
wages obviously and also some lower
wages um again depending on um uh exact
what the p a person's role is or job is
within that
industry so one thing I want to note
there was some discussion of savings and
household Savings in the last
presentation um and it's great that in
aggregate households have been saving
more but there is some variation um and
one of the places where we see variation
in terms of people's ability to pay for
expenses going into this crisis people's
ability to weather this crisis is if you
look at data from just before the
pandemic it shows that a lot of
households likely didn't have a lot of
savings or didn't have a lot of ability
to pay their regular expenses so uh the
US Federal Reserve um system did conduct
a survey they've conducted several they
conduct an annual survey and they've
conducted several recently October 2019
was the one prior to the pandemic and it
found that 37% of us adults so this is
surveying the United States as a whole
um so close to 4 and 10 adults indicated
they would not pay for an unexpected
$400 expense with cash savings or a
credit card to be paid in full at the
end of the month so they likely had
limited enough assets that they were
going to pay for an unexpected $400
expense which could be you know an
alternator on a car that you need to get
to work for example um with uh with
something other than cash savings or a
credit card uh that they would then be
able to avoid going into debt with so
they might be selling an asset um they
might be going into debt they might be
other you know otherwise unable to pay
it um indeed in that same survey in 2019
15% of us adults indicated they wouldn't
be able to pay pay their bills in full
that month when they were asked and if
you uh add in in that same survey an
unexpected $400 expense that would uh
16% of the people who said they could
pay for their bills on October 2019
would then not be able to pay with an
unexpected $400 expense so a lot of
people really close to the margin and
again this is before the pandemic now a
similar survey in July of 2020 actually
found that people were more likely to be
able to use Liquid cash for unexpected
expenses so that likely reflects those
economic impact payments those $1,200
checks um as well as those enhanced
employment benefits so again providing
support for the economy for people who
were um really close to the margin as it
is those are dollars that then get into
the economy and really likely helped
quite a bit um during calendar year 2020
um and hopefully will help again going
forward but um when we think about usual
household expenses there are a couple
different ways in terms of calculating
cost of living it's a it's sometimes a
challenging exercise but there are two
different calculators um that uh that
are um widely used one is the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology um
has a living wage calculator you can see
their graph on the left or their pie
chart on the left is for New Hampshire
as a whole and the economic policy
Institute family budget calculator on
the right is just for marac County they
don't provide a Statewide number um so I
picked sort of a Medi a county that's
closer to the middle if you will and
um and you can see on the left there's
two working adults with one child the
total uh the total cost the total
expenses uh or the total Co um income
needed to cover these expenses was about
$58,000 based on mit's calculations with
housing being the largest one and the
economic policy Institute looking at a
similar array of costs they actually
found Transportation was a little bit
larger than housing but um so they're so
these two models are looking a little
bit differently at Transportation costs
but um housing was again a very
significant one and uh their total uh
income was about uh just shy of $770,000
to meet their their costs so again
there's some differences in calculation
but these are highers numbers that are
much higher than for example what many
workers make um over the course of a
year um in some of these low wage
sectors so questions for the economy
going forward um and these are I think
key questions that you'll have to think
about when you're um projecting uh State
revenues based in part on economic
activity over the next uh two over the
next budget bium um one key question
that I have is Will workers be able to
rejoin the workforce efficiently um and
that could be is there a job available
in the field that they were working in
before is there a job available in a
different field that they are able to
adapt to are they able to rejoin um in
the field they were in before is it is
it safe right as the as the pandemic
hopefully Fades away over time and we
get closer and closer to that herd
immunity um are people able to rejoin
the workforce are they are they safely
able to rejoin the workforce and if they
can't rejoin the workforce in a in the
same field that they were in before are
there sufficient training or educational
opportunities that will enable them to
engage in a in a post-pandemic economy
it's probably going to look somewhat
different we don't exactly know how but
are there are there opportunities for
them to um to again sort of rejoin in a
way that is prod for them and and helps
helps the economy overall um will the
employment losses that we see um and the
income losses that we see resulting from
that lead to a more sort of regular
recession over time right now where we
have this sort of uneven recession that
is um that has been affected by um uh
what is ha we have this sort of uneven
recession that's been affected by sort
of the disperate impacts in different
parts of the economy um will we see that
some of the income losses especially at
low and middle end of the income
Spectrum have those been completely
recovered for by both public sector
activity uh policy changes and at
private sector finding other income from
other places or will we see an economic
slowdown and you saw a little bit in the
last presentation about that as well
which was a little bit a little bit
optimistic on that front um and I don't
mean optimistic in sort of in my
judgment I mean that that's a positive
Pat you'll have to unmute
yourself um hey thank you great
presentation um so my concern is that uh
you know once her immunity is reached
and uh we're gonna have a rush to open a
lot of businesses restaurants hotels
theaters entertainment centers you name
and even our ski areas have cut back um
not enough snow either but that's
another discussion but uh I'm concerned
that there's really not going to be my
real concern is there not going to be
enough workers to to fill all those jobs
and that there'll be an upward pressure
there will indeed be a natural upward
pressure on
wages uh I think I think I think the
lower level people are actually going to
benefit from that uh rages will go up
but do you think that not enough workers
are there to be an anchor to recovery
Total
Recovery
uh yeah so um one of one of my so I
agree I think that is a concern and I
think those concerns are driven in part
by long-term demographics in New
Hampshire that um that I I don't think
the to my knowledge the fundamentals
haven't changed as a result of this
pandemic we have seen more people moving
to the state um so that might affect it
some uh but those long-term demographics
are still exist and are still there
still part of the picture here in New
Hampshire um so I think again I think
that this is where um having
opportunities for people to uh enter the
workforce investing in people who might
otherwise be marginally attached to the
workforce so that um they you should
they choose to and should uh employers
be able to find them right be um be sort
of more full-fledged engagers if you
will in the workforce there are a lot of
folks who are um who have been on the
peripheries and we see we saw during
this economic recovery the tail end of
the economic recovery from the Great
Recession sort of more and more people
coming into the labor force over time
more than many economists expected
frankly
so my hope would be that there would be
a combination of sort of that effect of
investing in people who are otherwise
sort of marginally attached to the labor
force um really getting them the the
training and opportunities that they
might not otherwise have um and um and
benefiting from their engagement in
labor force as well as maybe some
immigration um and uh and I my hope is
that because this is sort of such a
swift economic event if we start to see
this unemployment rate the unemployment
rate continue to track or if we continue
to see the unemployment rate contract
and Shrink um in New Hampshire in
particular at such a fast rate that um
that a lot of Institutions right both
educational institutions and employers
will remember the um the sort of
Workforce constraints that we saw
immediately prior to the pandemic in New
Hampshire will be sort of freshen
everyone's minds and there will be more
sort of there'll be more opportunities
for coordination retraining and efforts
to make it so that people who are either
marginally attached to the labor force
or otherwise have have not received the
you know educational Investments have
not received the training opportunities
that they have in the past um that there
there will be more of those equ
opportunities there will be more of
those Investments and that will get more
people into the labor force to help
address that concern because I think it
is a real one going forward okay we'll
take three more questions and then you
can continue from next is Senator
Ros thank you Mr chairman Phil um
through the middle of October
New Hampshire has received about $85
million in additional Federal Medicaid
funds that's
6.2% extra fmap do you have any estimate
of what we might expect to receive
through the end of the
biennium yeah unfortunately Senator
Rosenwald it's a great question and one
of the key ways in which the federal
government has provided support to uh to
New Hampshire's budget it certainly l
far um I don't have an estimate for the
through the end of the bium my
understanding um of of that additional
fmap increase that an enhanced Medicaid
match is uh it is dependent on the
federal Public Health Emergency um so I
don't know how long that's going to last
uh But whichever as long as some part of
the quarter is covered by federal Public
Health the federal Public Health
Emergency then that enhanced fmap
applies to that um to those quarterly
payments that are made um through the
federal medic program but unfortunately
I don't have a number to to estimate
that Senator
Hennessy thank you Mr chair uh Phil
thank you for taking my question I my
question I believe it was on page four
you had a very interesting graph that
showed
um
the uh yes the low wage the middle wage
and the high wage have you ever looked
at this with the with an overlay of the
jobs that are available in these three
different categories and the changes in
them because the reason I ask is that I
mean just from um employers contacting
me but also just reading any newspaper I
see a lot of jobs available is it and
and I just would like to get your
opinion on that see if you've done that
before right so there may be there may
be some interaction between what we're
seeing here in terms of the in terms of
employment changes and what we're seeing
in um changes in the civilian labor
force right um so I think that there is
I think that part of this mismatch that
we see or part of this um mismatch
between you know some jobs are available
and there aren't they don't appear to be
workers available for them and there are
some workers who would prefer to be
earning income in the economy and aren't
um aren't able to find work or seeing
that you know the low wage job sectors
obviously are a ways down um I think
some of that mismatch is why it's really
important to um have have sort of an
intentional process of being able to
uh take folks who either have received
you know less investment in terms of
training in terms of education and
connecting them to job opportunities um
I think because I agree I think that
there is some of that and there was some
of that prior to the or pardon me in the
aftermath of the Great Recession as well
there was some um employment mismatch um
and there's questions around how much of
that is cyclical and how much of that is
structural and it's something that's
actually been a fair bit of research
around of in the recovery from the Great
recession it's hard to say because this
economic shock is so different exactly
what that's going to look like in the
recovery here um and because it's such a
shorter time horizon or potentially
hopefully a shorter time Horizon than
the Great Recession but um but I think
that I think that you you do raise a key
question around why are we seeing these
sort of um these sort of different
experiences um and I think that once we
once the the sort of natural disaster
portion of this recession right the
pandemic of this recession subsides then
we'll see a little bit more about how
that shakes out I think it's a hard
question to answer at this point um so
I'm I'm sorry that those are the best
thoughts I have for you at this point
Senator henness thank you okay then
there'll be representa taka followed by
Senator guer and then we'll hold the
questions until um Phil finishes because
he has 17 more slides to do after that
so representative Tucker thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being with us
today uh I didn't see in your comments
or your slides the apparent differences
in how the this uh crisis has affected
women and how it's affected men and the
role of child care
preschool uh and generally education
plays into that and perhaps perhaps you
have slides later about that
um but I think that's something that's
really quite different than prior uh
recessions or the Great Recession and I
wondered if you could comment on that
sure yeah and it is absolutely different
um than what we saw during the Great
Recession um during the Great Recession
um the majority of people who are
applying for uh unemployment assistance
in New Hampshire were men um and in the
first three months of the pandemic if
you will or this the second quarter of
calendar year 2020 um the New Hampshire
employment security reported that about
59% of the people applying for
unemployment compensation were women um
and so that's a pretty massive shift
this is a again A A recession that is
more focused on the service sectors in
the economy some of the pardon me some
of the um sectors that more
traditionally employ women or tend to
employ higher percentages of women
rather than men um and we've seen that
nationally there's been some research
around who is dropping out of the labor
force so again that's back to this um uh
back to this uh the blue line here
showing why are people not in the labor
force and we've seen some research that
suggest that not only women but women
with children are more likely to have
dropped out of the labor force um than
than not only men but women without
children as well so that suggests
there's definitely a child care
component here there's definitely a
component where as it's safe to reopen
schools will we see more people rejoin
the labor force we see more women with
children able to rejoin the labor force
um so that has that's sort of the um the
upshot when it comes to how how some of
these uh metrics might move and what it
might do with the for the economy that
being said there's a lot of people a lot
of women with children uh in particular
based on based on the statistics we've
seen who who dropped out of the labor
force who weren't able to engage in
employment um that has ramifications for
their career in the long term and their
earning potential and their ability to
engage in the economy in the long term
as well um and I think that that's an
important consideration going forward
especially when we look at the economy
um for you for the next years in the
gerer thank you Mr chairman uh Phil good
presentation as always uh you go back to
that slide that you uh pulled up
initially for Senator Hennessy that
show so my question is is of those three
brackets do do you have any numerical or
percentage of the workforce numbers for
those brackets is particularly those
that did not participate in the in the
economic Prosperity that lower bracket
yeah so New Hampshire in New Hampshire
yeah so for these numbers for New
Hampshire I don't have those but I can
see if I can find those in those in this
research for you sendor guide and send
those along as well um but they we do
see so we know what the incomes are and
these These are based on what was what
these jobs paid in 2019 um the incomes
are for the high wager greater than
60,000 27,000 to 60,000 in the middle
and then low wage is less than $27,000
so um again you know median household
income in New Hampshire we know in 2019
was about 75,000 but that's a household
that's again roughly two and a half
people um so uh the median in terms of
the median wage and jobs I would um I
would want to go back and match up those
numbers with you as opposed to match up
those numbers and provide them to you um
as opposed to um as opposed to trying to
remember them off the top of my head but
I can provide those to um to both
committees all right just by way of
quick commentary Mr
chairman the the the women with children
component that is not recovering I think
is largely due to the school issue where
we have many of our schools going hybrid
or remote completely intermittently and
the child care issue is a huge one thank
you okay well why don't you continue
Phil Right absolutely Ely um so uh so
some more questions for the economy
going forward and we actually already
covered a fair number of these questions
um I do think additional Federal action
will be a key consideration um and how
how does that affect the economy overall
how does the effect the ability of
residents to make ends meet themselves
obviously there's an interaction there
with the broader economy um what role
will the State play in supporting the
economic recovery um there are a lot of
State services that are provided that
are pretty key for people to be able to
not only invest in their Education and
Training but also um uh also uh make
sure that they stay in their homes and
um uh and have resources going forward
um what happens to the international
economy and what happens to trade as a
result of that uh even as we advance
towards H herd immunity hopefully over
the course of this year uh in New
Hampshire and in the United States um
what happens in terms of uh in terms of
international trade impacts uh and Inter
and ational economic interactions and
other forms that affects what the
economy looks like going forward for
over many years um we may not get to
herd immunity in a lot of places if you
will um uh for for many years to come it
really depends on the vaccine roll out
the vaccine availability the um the
Investments made in countries that are
don't have the resources to invest in
themselves um in the same way in terms
of buying vaccines for large spats of
their population so I think that's a
question going forward
also what happens in the post-pandemic
economy to commercial property values um
what happens to how businesses organize
themselves geographically what happens
to tourism there may be less
International tourism that might
actually help New Hampshire if more
people are engaging in tourism locally
we did see some of that during 2020 um
what and so there are many other areas
where I think there are questions like
this so I want to shift to talking a
little bit about State revenues um I
think understanding that you're going to
looking to project State revenues into
the next budget bium um I want to look
back a little bit and note that we've
had a dramatic improvements in these
forecasts especially since the last time
I um I was presenting to members of the
House Ways and Means Committee um the
these are the forecasts for State fiscal
year 2021 over several different
iterations um we can see that in May and
June both the state agencies and the
house ways in Means Committee had
estimates for 2021 of a you know maybe
low 200 to high High $300 million
shortfall in the general and education
trust funds obviously a very significant
number um in July and September the
state agencies sort of folded back those
forecasts a little bit to around $240
million and in November they presented
to all of you some of the um some of the
updated forecasts which total between a
4 million and a 76 pardon me million
dollar shortfall in the general and
education trust funds obviously a much
more manageable number and we've seen
that these forecasts of as they've
changed over time reflect our you
reflect our understanding of the sort of
economic crisis that we're in um again
the the modeling based on employment
early in 2020 was suggesting some very
significant shortfalls but we've seen
this recession behave quite differently
and we see that in the actual revenues
as well so these are the actual revenues
on a cash basis to the general and
education trust funds for the uh for
each month of calendar year 2020 you can
see State fiscal year 2020 is on the
left side and state fiscal year 2021 on
the right and you see that dip the that
drop associated with um the initial
impacts of the pandemic we very we had
saw very significant revenue losses in
some of those months relative to the
state budget plan which is that zero
line but we've seen since then and thus
far in state fiscal year 2021 revenues
not only doing better than was expected
based on what we were seeing in the
pandemic but also better than was
expected in the state budget plan um and
the revenue estimates that were put
together in September of
2019 well before the pandemic so it's
it's really actually remarkable and if
we look at we if we look at a little bit
more historical context for General and
education trust fund revenues overall
this graph shows the three-month rolling
averages relative to the prior year and
the percent changes there and we can see
that some of that faster economic growth
helped in 2014 and 2015 and really
started showing up in the revenues in
2015 and 2016 we see the um the next
sort of Rise that you see that's labeled
there is the result of the December 2017
tax cuts and jobs act a lot of companies
were repatriating um a lot of
multinational companies were
repatriating dollars from
overseas those dollars some of those
were captured by the business profits
tax base those were expected to be
one-time funds so we expected to see a
drop off after that we obviously saw a
relatively precipitous drop again you
see the bottom Spike on there is uh the
the uh the NAT if you will of the whole
graph is what's happened in the first
half of calendar year 2020 um however in
the second half and into State fiscal
year 2021 we've seen revenues not only
rebound from that but also again be
higher than they were the year before
higher than revenues in the second half
of 2020 being higher than they were in
the second half of 2019 again talking
about calendar years there so it's
really substantial and and why might
this be what are some of the things that
have contributed to this um that might
you know talking about that might help
inform what we see going forward so here
the revenue source that has taken the
largest hit and is the second largest
tax revenue Source the state actually
collects um is the meals and rentals tax
um the meals and rentals tax obviously
was impacted in April and May you can
see those actual numbers in Orange in
May um the the projections produced by
the state uh the state agencies on a
looking at a monthly basis you can see
um that the Department of Revenue
Administration expected it to dip a
little bit more than it actually did in
the summer there was a fair bit of
innovation and a lot of businesses were
um especially um restaurant me
restaurants which are 80% of the tax
based here um we're we're innovating and
finding ways to get consumers in the
doors um you can see the next set of
projections in November um which are
borne out thus far in the December data
um don't suggest suggest this will
continue to add to the budget deficit as
opposed to the Surplus relative to what
was in the state budget plan again that
$ Z
line um cigarette sales have been much
higher than expected and that's
something that we see again higher than
even the state revenue plan that's
something that's expected to continue
going forward through the rest of this
fiscal year again from the Department of
Revenue Administration um that is driven
maybe in part by people smoking more um
if there's greater stressers out there
which there are um uh in part by crossb
sales because of policy changes in
Massachusetts that I believe Dr spoke
about yesterday um and it may some of
that may be people stocking up as well
not knowing what's going to happen um
you know in the next month or two
related to the pandemic real estate
sales and I know you're going to hear
from Ben Frost later today real estate
sales have uh rebounded in a way that it
was not expected um usually this moves
with the economy more generally again
we're seeing these uneven economic
impacts so um the actual
um is quite a bit higher than what was
planned and what was projected earlier
in the year and uh and the question in
my mind around this the real key
question is what happens with inventory
um both sales volume and sales values
are up for single family homes relative
to the prior year which was already a
hot market and with little inventory so
what happens with inventory going
forward was I think be really important
here um the hur's interest in dividends
tax um also has seen um re has been
generating Revenue sort of above
expectations suggesting that for folks
who have significant assets and who are
paying interest in dividends tax uh um
to New Hampshire um we're seeing that
those assets are are generating Revenue
not that far off from plan in recent
months and again there was a filing
deadline shift so that's why we see a
little bit of that um seawing if you
will um but those are still holding up
in a way that you might not expect in
sort of a regular
recession and then business taxes have
been the primary driver of what we see
as the revenue Surplus so far this
fiscal year um and uh and the Department
of Revenue Administration again these
are these are performing better than
expected better than we would see in a
regular recession the Department of
Revenue Administration has noted that
there are some businesses that are doing
well and some businesses that are doing
poorly again it's a really sort of
uneven and not typical recession um but
also that large businesses are doing
relatively well and are doing better
than was expected um and we heard in a
little bit in the last presentation
about about corporate profit as well um
and those large businesses are an
important part of the picture so this uh
table is derived from uh um data um
produced by the Department of Revenue
Administration uh this is the business
profits tax base for ta for tax year
2018 um looking at the different uh size
businesses in terms of their taxable
profits under the New Hampshire business
profits tax you can see that over on
that left-hand column tax year 2018 is
the most recent year we have these data
for so um you can see the cumulative
percentage that pay that has taxable
business profits of at least that number
on the left hand column um in that
middle column you can see that
cumulative percentage of filers and you
can see the cumulative percentage of
Revenue paid on the right so if we look
just at the Top Line you'll see that for
businesses that uh had taxable profits
attributable to New Hampshire after a
portion M of at least 12.6 million that
was actually was about it was 76
businesses is that on10th of a percent
of filers and those businesses paid
close to half of the total business
profits tax that was collected so the
reason I'm showing you this table is to
emphasize how important those large
businesses are for understanding what is
happening with business profits tax
revenue another way to emphasize that is
um if we look at the filers by type um
by type of business um Proprietors which
could include you know sole Proprietors
and uh so self-employed individuals um
make up the largest share of filer types
and you can see corporations and
Partnerships are also significant as
well that orange slice are Water's Edge
filers so um uh a a type of combined
reporting that generally reflects
multi-state and Multinational businesses
they made up about 6% of filers but
keeping the colors the same in terms of
the revenue that was paid they made up
62% of all the revenue so again what are
typically large multi-state
multinational businesses are really
important part of tax base now I'll note
this was tax year 2018 so these numbers
are they're most recent numbers they're
probably a little bit higher because of
some of that repatriation but even if
you look at tax year 2017 it was about
57% or 57 or 58% so again the largest
businesses are key part of the business
profit tax
base um the uh business Enterprise tax
base is a little bit more distributed so
you can see to get to about half of the
revenue collected through that you have
to get to the top8 % of businesses in
terms of their business Enterprise tax
base as opposed to the top Point uh
.1% um so that gives you a little bit a
sense of how the business Enterprise tax
interacts a little differently and the
interest in dividends tax is also one
where um we see that the top income
earners are really important to
understanding what's going to happen
with interest and dividends tax revenues
so for example people earning two or
filers I should say people are or um
joint filers generally um who are
earning $200 ,000 or more in just
interest in dividend income so this is
in interest and dividend income Alone um
paid about half of the interest and
dividends tax um again a little under
half in tax year
2018 but while we're talking about these
important state taxes however and they
are pretty key to State finances it's
important to remember that of state and
local taxes collected the property tax
collected and expended at the local
level dwarfs a lot of these individual
state taxes so you could see the five
largest state tax revenue sources in uh
State fiscal year 2020 um not counting
the Statewide education property tax
because that's raised and retained
locally so that's added on to that local
property tax levy again much more
significant than even our largest uh
state level tax the business profits tax
so I think questions uh for the future
relative to revenues in the economy will
a more sort of regular recession happen
and will it lead to a general slowdown
in revenues as opposed to the sort of
disperate impact that we've seen seen
this disperate impact different in
different sectors has meant that sectors
that happen to match some key state
revenue sources for New Hampshire like
large corporations have actually been
performing well will they continue to
perform well and it could be that they
very well may that's just a question of
how does what's happening in the economy
and in different sectors of the economy
interact with our tax bases in New
Hampshire um do slower wage growth has
happened during the last recession limit
State revenues um it could be that we
don't see that SL lower wage growth it
could be that we do that's something
that I think is important to watch for
and consider are there long-term
International Trade impacts that affect
business of profits tax revenues in
particular I think that's a key question
um do restaurants recover and in
particular do they recover in commercial
areas I'm thinking of some of our
downtowns in New Hampshire um that could
be that there is not the same sort of
recovery there in terms of people going
out to lunch whatever it may be um and
then what happens to both residential
and commercial property values we may
see them Go in different directions
commercial property values I think are a
big question mark going forward and what
are the implications for pressure on
local property tax revenues so some key
takeaways the covid-19 crisis had a
Swift and massive impact it had the most
severe effects on those with the fewest
resources um there are pretty Stark
differences relative to what we would
see in a regular recession there's not
this General slowdown it's a little bit
more varied um and federal assistance
played a really important impact in the
2020 economy being as good as it was
given the conditions um and given some
of the other indicators that we see and
that's true in New Hampshire too pardon
me and tax revenues from businesses
tobacco products and real estates have
done surprisingly well but the uneven
impacts of the crisis have been clear in
those revenue streams um and larger
businesses higher income earners and
property markets and values are going to
be important for Key State and
particularly that last one local Revenue
sources as well I think there is some
risk that this uneven slow wage growth
and uneven industry impacts hinder a
robust Equitable and sustainable
recovery and that may be a way that we
don't see in the Topline numbers as well
like the Topline numbers May mask some
of that um uh some of that unevenness in
the recovery so I'm happy to take any
questions I know I only have a couple
minutes left um but I appreciate the
questions partway through and I know
this is a lot of material um I'm happy
to talk you through any any bit of it
that you'd
like okay uh question from
representative
alme thank you Mr chairman uh
Phil we've just gone to Mar market-based
sourcing in the business profits tax and
the business Enterprise tax uh and we
are about to go next year to single
sales factor which I think could have a
much larger impact have you looked at
all at what the waterers Edge and the
other large corporations do in terms of
their sales to the exterior of the state
which is what single sales Factor would
not tax yeah and I think that's an
excellent question and an excellent
point I think that um single sales
Factor does uh introduce the prospect of
perhaps more volatility with changes in
the economy I haven't been able to look
and see uh what the uh especially the
Waters Edge uh reporters um have in
terms of the breakdown of single sales
Factor versus the the three factors um
so I think that's an excellent question
um I imagine that Dr would be able to
dig into those numbers much more deeply
than I can based on the information that
they have available um but I I I think
that's a key
consideration I'm sorry I don't have a
Bry Patrick you gonna have to unmute
yourself
did it again thanks thanks Phil um it
seems to be there seems to be a lot of
wealth moving into New Hampshire given
the increases in the red and we know
that the it's really putting upward
pressure on the uh housing prices uh so
do you think there's a correlation there
with what may happen with interest in
dividends because those wealthy people
will have Investments that will be
taxed um or do you think that's even uh
uh will move the needle at all um it it
could very well move the needle um if we
are if we look at the migration data and
find that we're talking about many more
thousands of people moving to New
Hampshire and um if you were to make
some assumption about how many of those
people are really high wealth
individuals that again drive that
interest in dividends tax base um it
could move the needle on that front
again remember there were only about I
think in the table was about 66,000
filers for the interest in dividends tax
um so several thousand could could
change things um however I I I think it
would be hard to hard to forecast that I
think uh things like the stock market
more generally are going to add more
variability probably than that but
that's just a hunch um uh so I I think
it's good that you're thinking about it
but I don't know that it will move the
needle that much or at least in a way
that's that
forecastable okay thank you yep you're
welcome looks like we're right on time
here and uh we have time for one more
question but I do not see a hand so Phil
thank you again for an excellent
presentation and and we expect to hear
more from you in the near future all
right thank you very much chairman major
I look forward to the opportunity to
speak thanks everyone for your time this
morning okay we are right on time for
our next
presentation uh which is going to be by
Dave ja who's a senior vice president of
policy in the New Hampshire business and
industry
Association and and Dave will be
discussing the state's housing market
and housing challenges and I believe
Dave you you have uh some representation
from a couple of the businesses with you
yours
Jen Mr du is on the call um he just
unmute as you as I've now demonstrated
challenged thank you uh Mr chair and
members of the House and Senate Ways and
Means Committee we were very happy to be
invited to participate and I thought the
best way to provide sort of a
um photograph of what's going on with uh
New Hampshire's economy especially in
the manufacturing sector was to invite
three Bia members and they're from very
different types of companies so let me
quickly introduce them and then we'll
move into their presentations and then
be happy to address any questions that
committee members will have uh first I'd
like to introduce Tom white he's
president of New England wire
Technologies New England wire
Technologies is in Lisbon New Hampshire
it's a privately held Employee Stock
ownership company with more than 400
employees and Facilities consisting of
over 385,000 square feet of
manufacturing quality testing tooling
machine fabrication and office space
their on-site manufacturing process
include wire drawing plating braiding
cabling insulating and Extrusion
services and I'm sure Tom will provide a
little bit more detail as a part of his
presentation next we have Val zanchuck
Val is president of graphic cast Inc
graphic cast was founded in Jaffrey New
Hampshire in 1978 and currently has 21
employees so we've gone from the
spectrum of a large manufacturer down to
a rather small one the company provides
uh contract casting and machining
Manufacturing Services to over 70
industrial customers and offers a
portfolio of 170 different unique parts
and finally we have with us Cheryl
Lawson Cheryl is the COO and CFO for the
Lawson group Lawson group is a
family-owned business they've been
around for over 40 years and are based
in Conquer New Hampshire they employ uh
more than 40 people and specialize in
health and safety Consulting providing
employee Wellness services and serving
as thirdparty administrators for workers
compensation programs including a
manufacturers program with almost 200
Manufacturing Company members so I
thought she would be uh extremely useful
in talking about the experiences of many
of her manufacturing trust members but
let me first turn to Tom white president
of New England wire Technologies and Tom
let me turn it over to
you good morning everybody can you hear
me good
morning yes U again my name is Tom white
president of New England uh wi
Technologies Dave they have a very good
rundown of who we are and what we are um
we're the main manufacturer in Lisbon
area and um we are a type of company
that I would call is non-commodity we
make specific wire speci special need
and the strength of our company or our
employees period we've got a great work
ethic we have like I said about 40 400
employees and I will say that 2020 was a
challenge um we timing is everything in
business and we decided to uh earlier to
engage a brand new Erp
system that was started on January 1st
of 2020 and uh and then of course in
February we were challenged with the the
covid situation so we were challenged
with two major difficulties for the
company in
2020 in
2019 uh we had a goal of sales of
approximately $80
million at the end of
2019 we had sales of
82 .9 million which is about three the
3.4% increase in sales that are
projected because we had some certain
scenarios during a year we we projected
for
2020 of an
$82.5 Million worth of sales and in the
first four months of 2020 it looked like
we were going to achieve up to
potentially 7 to 8% increase over that
projection and then covid hit
we ended up the year with 73
approximately $73 million worth of
sales and which was a
11.5% reduction in our
sales and again I I would say looking
back at it I think our achievement was
the greatest achievement in the history
of the company or at least in the 40
years that I've been an employee at
Newland
wire our staff was in
engaged um the effort was tremendous it
was a next man up or next person up how
you want to look at it and I can't be
proud of our employees and what they
were we um we had a situation where the
number of orders were typically equal
but instead of getting a $50,000 order
we might have got a $5,000
order we were fortunate enough to be
identified as an essential company
and we certainly are essential because
we meet uh many demands in the medical
the defense and certainly in the power
industry we were fortunate enough even
with the sales level we got if we hadn't
got about a $2.5 Million worth of
orders um in the medical area for
ventilators the ventilators was huge for
us and we turned our facility around
four ventilator cable um again very
proud of our people what we did what we
accomplished um the disconcerning thing
to me um was uh it was great but every
inch of wire we sent to
China which was disconcerting to me to
be honest with you because I I really
had hoped that it would have been all
made in the US but um again we we did it
we did a great job now um for 2021 we're
looking at $
79.1 million in sales this year which is
about a 8% increase over our actual
sales last year um our our challenges we
have we still have challenges even
though the unemployment rate is what it
is uh and I'm not a believer in that
rate to be honest with you we still have
challenges finding people to
work and um again we we our compensation
rates are equal or better than any
employee in the area we have an Esau
program we have a profit sharing program
uh last year we shared uh about 56 hours
of bonus with our
employees and um I I look at us as as
being a very positive employee
ER and um I'm positive about the
direction of the company I'm positive
direction of the economy um
I'm not a politician um I I'm one who
believes that we're all in this together
and I wish that both sides would look at
in the best interest of the people not
necessarily in the best interest of a
political party and I think you people
will and uh I know we'll survive this
thing and in the long run I communicate
to our employees very simply that we'll
be better when you get challenged you
come up with strategy that make you a
better company and I I tell you I can't
be like I said before I'm ring again how
much pride I have on our employees how
they've overcome things we at one point
had approximately 50 people out of our
facility based on the uh five or six
qualifications of being able to leave
the company whether because they had
children who were out of school whatever
it may be and I I tell you people
stepped up we our whole manufacturing
Force stayed in the facility we did we
followed all the CDC guidelines we got
bought equipment for um
sterilization we did the mask we did
send our sales group out of the office
for the fact that we thought they they
could and they did work um fine on and
remote I'm one that wanted our people to
be work here because I think you can
develop a team when you talked to people
face to face and we lost some teamwork
with people being out whatever but we
did hold it together we are presently
now everyone is back in the
facility and I I'm very positive for the
future and I may be the president of New
England wire I'm probably best of being
a cheerleader for New England wire
because the positions today you need to
be positive you need to be uh show
people there's a way to improve there's
a way we are are going to get through
are thank you Tom uh Mr chair do you
want me to pause for questions or do you
want me to go into the next panelist why
don't we do the three panelists and then
we'll come back to questions fine uh our
next panelist is Val Jan zanu the
president of graphic cast a manufacturer
in Jaffrey in the manad region and Val
is apparently broadcasting from the
rather aial offices that come with being
the president of that company and he has
a presentation he'll be sharing his
screen so Val let me turn it over to you
yeah I I wish that were my office uh
yeah as as uh Dave mentioned uh we've
been in the Jaffrey area since 1978 with
21 employees uh we were up to about 25
or 21 right now trying to balance things
out uh as as Dave mentioned we are a
contract manufacturer so we we make
things for other people uh we have no
products that are branded under under
our name so we have to be uh pretty
agile and pretty flexible in our ability
to respond to the the needs of those
customers and um as they mentioned we
have a a portfolio of about 170
different parts that we make for those
customers but um we really have no
control over when they're going to order
from us so we're we're operating
basically uh at at the will of of not
only the those companies but also sort
of at the at the uh Direction and
influence of the national economy and um
the other thing we contend with is that
there's a there's a a difference in time
between when we get an order for
something and when we actually produce
it uh just because of how things line up
in our queue so typically right now
we're running on a 16 to 18 week
difference between when an order is
placed to actually when we produce the
part and ship it to the the the customer
so as you'll see in the graphs that I'll
show you uh those lags are you know are
represented by by the types of
volatility and fluctuation that we have
uh the other issue that we have uh I
call it the goldilock syndrome is
because we don't have control over the
business coming in and we don't know
when it's going to hit whatever we're
trying to be able to balance uh our
employment level and the inventory of
equipment we have on the floor so that
on average you know we can meet that
that demand uh sometimes the demand
drops off and we have too many people
sometimes the demand picks up and you
know we can't put enough hours in in a
week to to keep up with it um so that's
you know how we have to try to juggle
things and I did mention um if you run a
business like this you definitely need a
small or a very strong stomach uh some
people lose sleep I don't but um it it
has its ups and downs so just to give
you uh some some sense of the impact if
we look at the the bookings these are
the orders that we actually get going
all the way back to 2007 uh you can see
the impact of of the recession and some
of the other things that took place uh
nationally and globally on our
business 2007 was actually the best year
we ever had with the company after the
Great Recession and you can see the
impact that that had on our business in
terms of uh bookings you know we dropped
about a third to 40% uh many of our
customers uh did not come back they just
disappeared
so between then and 2012 or so we
rebuilt the business then there was a
small slowdown in 2012 that affected us
then uh we went along fairly well until
about April of 2015 there was a a global
manufacturing recession uh was very very
abrupt and it it took us about four
years as you can see here um to get out
of that recession and actually build
ourselves back up to a a range that we
were operating uh profitably and fairly
uh steadily and then Co hit um so we're
we're down quite a bit bookings uh 25%
down 2000 calendar 2020 compared to
2019 and if you know we look at that in
a little more detail the last two years
on a monthly basis you can see that
through 2019 into the early parts of
20120 there was a lot of volatility uh
in terms of bookings we'd have some
months where we'd you know get almost
half a million dollars in orders and
then the next month we'd be down to
$100,000 so you know very very volatile
um for us the covid impact really
started around July uh during the first
few months of of of the the CID impact
uh you know April May June time frame we
were quite busy uh we have one customer
who customer who makes uh diagnostic
equipment for you know measuring covid
and Sample
uh their business was booming we
couldn't make Parts fast enough for them
but once July hit uh the momentum that
we had built up through the first part
of the year uh fell off dramatically and
as I show here in uh August of 20120 we
almost had no orders at all which is the
only time that's happened in 42 years of
company history so you go from August of
$384,000 in new orders to August of 2020
and it was almost zero uh that's the
impact that that that Co has had on us
it's very very dramatic if we look at
our shipments and again over the same
time period This is a monthly shipment
schedule you can see the impact of the
recession as we dropped through 20078
and N we picked up to 2012 dropped off a
little in the summer there uh built the
business back up to 2015 went through a
long recession of very very flat sales
for four years and then just as we were
coming out of that re session covid hit
and we've dropped off again and if we
look again at a at a monthly impact you
can see what happened there monthly
shipments were again volatile but a
little bit more steady than the bookings
but then um in in July you know the June
and July time frame are our our
shipments dropped by
50% uh and in the third quarter July
August in September uh we're down 41%
compared to the same quarter of last
year uh year to year we're down 12 but
that particular quarter was bad but as
you can see from you know July through
the end of the year a slight Improvement
but not nearly enough to make make us
profitable so we're we're running right
now we're running just about Break Even
um so we're really seeing the impact of
covid on us uh we really have a hard
time projecting forward because uh we
really don't know what's going to happen
to our customers um you know some of
them have come back uh reasonably well
others are still
struggling um long range planning for us
is probably about a month um you know if
I tried to project out a year I don't
think I would be able to get even close
to what may happen I know from our
backlog that this quarter first quarter
of
2021 looks pretty good it's it's a
continuation upward of that Trend but it
it's nowhere near where we had to be and
we suspect by the end of our fiscal year
which is June 30th we'll probably be
down 15 to 20% compared to the prior
fiscal year so it'll it'll be another
year uh probably of of a of a loss on
the bottom line and um you know it'll
it'll still take us a little while to
climb back out of this so uh very
frustrating and that we've we were on
the verge of really breaking out of a
recession um now we've been hit with
this and there's there's really
no no certainty and I think that's the
biggest issue we have right now it's
very very difficult for us to predict
predict uh with any degree of certainty
exactly how things are going to go you
know in the next year I can tell you in
the next three months things look pretty
good but beyond that it's it's
relatively flat um and we really don't
have that much visibility so it's it's
going to be a tough year for us you know
we haven't um you know cut back on
salaries uh We've we've we've managed to
squeeze out some investment and some new
equipment uh but it's it's a real
juggling act trying to balance
everything out so we're as as previously
mentioned we you know we optimistic
about our business and its
capabilities um and we're trying to
operate within the the boundaries of of
the uncertainty that we have right now
with the uh with the virus so we suspect
uh you know this year is going to be
relatively flat uh for us um we don't
see a lot of growth growth opportunities
if anything just a very slow uh recovery
out of uh out of the depths of the uh
Pand mic so that's that's about it thank
you thank you Val and now let me turn to
Cheryl klei Lawson Cheryl is the Chief
Operating Officer and Chief Financial
Officer for the Lawson group they are
not a manufacturer but they have a lot
of manufacturing members in their
workers comp trust and they also uh
provide services to a number of other
non-manufacturing companies I thought
she would be good to wrap up our panel
just uh taking a look at from the 30,000
foot view what she's hearing from her
client so Cheryl let me turn it over to
you thank you David good morning um
thank you for uh thank you for the
invitation to to address the the the
committee um as he said as David had
said we are U the lawon group 80% of
what we do is we are a third-party
administrator for three of the state's
self-insured workers compensation trusts
the largest trust being manufacturing
where we handle workers compensation for
uh today 215 workers U manufacturing
companies um some you know ranging from
all sizes large companies small
companies we also handle workers
compensation for about a 100 uh Lumber
related Industries to recognize loggers
cabinet makers all things wood uh and
then there is another trust that we
manage which is Healthcare and Human
Services and that trust has about 72
members all in total uh we manage about
$20 million of premium in the state um
the other side of our business which is
20% of what we do is U employer workers
health and safety and we've been doing
that for about 40 years um interestingly
in our line of business in the non- comp
so just to touch on our own business of
health and safety uh this past year we
saw a 50% reduction in our Revenue 50%
uh which was really staggering folks
weren't opening their businesses it was
all covid related um you know and we
There Was You someone explained to me in
a presentation I watched earlier in the
year um about this so-called recession
it is a is it a supply recession is it a
demand recession and you know if it's a
demand recession it's higher it's harder
to come out of and they really believe
that covid is a supply recession right
it's we just don't have access to do
what we want to do or go where we want
to go because of covid and as soon as
all things covid are are improving
whether it's vaccines testing what have
you you know the the the demand goes
back up immediately right so we're
hoping it's an
improved um you know it's a it's a
quicker return to to normal um on our
workers compensation side I will tell
you that we won't see the impact of the
pandemic in 2020 until we complete all
payroll audits because that's how um our
our business model runs and we're
starting to um get into payroll audits
in q1 and Q2 for all of last year I can
tell you that of all the members almost
400 companies no one no one shut their
doors no one called us up and said I'm
having such a drastic reduction in
Workforce that I need to revise my
workers compensation estimates right and
we firmly believe that that was because
of the stimulus PPP money that was in
the Main Street money that was available
to all businesses right we we don't know
what it will look like come 2021 year um
but we honestly believe that the PPP
money kept people going um you know we
talk to all of our businesses constantly
to understand how they're doing what
they're seeing in the in in in the you
know in the current conditions and I
will tell you that we our manufacturing
group is our largest group and there's a
variety of people there's residential
business Building Products oems
commercial building products um they
they run the gamut of of Manufacturers
and the common theme that we hear is
predictability everybody wants
predictability you know if I say to
someone if I say to Val what's your
perfect perfect business model he'd say
well uh if I had no employees if I had
no equipment and no customers life would
be great right um that's you know that's
that's manufacturing
humor but we know that's that's not a
fact right so all those three things
customers equipment and and and
employees create a level of
predictability but it's a
predictability that we all as business
owners can manage if you throw the
pandemic into the mix there's there's
little virtually little to no
predictability and there are three
things really that folks are struggling
with one is the supply chain right we
have seen the vulnerability of our
supply chain during this pandemic like
no other time you know it is quite
obvious that China is the world's
Factory and given the fact that our
manufacturers don't produce all of the
parts necessary for their complete work
processes they work product um product
production times have slowed down the
delivery of product to customers if
their customers are still ordering has
slowed down and we have no way to
control that supply chain and we don't
know what that looks like in 2021 either
that's that's an issue out of our
control the second issue and Tom touched
on it as well um is employment you know
employment has always been a struggle
here in New Hampshire you know it's a
it's a blessing and a curse that we have
the low unemployment rates that we have
and if you normalize for travel and
tourism and hotel and restaurant you
know our unemployment rates are almost
back to pre-pandemic
rates our employer our employers
struggled with the stimulus package with
the additional enhanced unemployment
benefit people were able to stay home
and make more money than going to work
they're concerned with what we're
hearing that's coming out of Washington
that we'll be in the same place this
coming
year right so so we have a concern about
the workforce and the ability to higher
some of our employers are struggling
with the availability of testing for
covid right can we make testing more
available maybe on site for employers so
they don't have that wait time so
they're not
pulling um co-workers to fill in at an
overtime level while folks are waiting
at home for test results that may be
negative right so is there a shift there
that can that can you know that we can
expedite
testing um the other the other Common
Thread that that I see um is is is
revenue right it's the inability to
predict your Revenue right we have
customers whose we have me trust members
rather whose customers are
municipalities who aren't spending we
have members whose customer based are um
higher education who are not spending uh
there's a contraction in the in the
Salesforce there are some businesses
albeit as we heard Phil um say just
before this that are doing very well
sure it's the larger businesses much
larger businesses who have access to
more resources but most of our
businesses and most of the business here
in New Hampshire are your smaller
businesses right who who don't have
those resources and they're getting very
creative right folks who are putting
more money towards Capital Improvements
in their shop how can I improve my l
because I know I'm not going to be able
to hire the necessary folks how can I
improve um you know um my my production
how can I improve with with some with
some Capital that I'm able to you know
to to secure and they've they were able
to last year some companies Inc improve
their balance sheet with capital because
of PPP
funding it's not going to be there this
year so so I can say in in summary it's
what we're hearing is uncertainty and
predictability right and now you throw
in one more piece of what would be
coming out of Washington for increased
tax rates uh for businesses uh a push on
an increase in a minimum wage those are
all disconcerting uh and they have
business owners just
pausing um so that that's what that's
what we're seeing from our businesses
and and B and and and Tom couldn't said
it any better so I appreciate the
opportunity to come forward and just
share with you what what I'm what I'm
hearing and the conversations we're
having so thank you very much thanks
David thank you Cheryl and uh Tom and
Val and let me turn it over to you Mr
chair we are happy to try and answer any
have thank you and I thank Val Cheryl
and Tom for their
presentation it really helps the
committee to understand the the depth of
the issues that have caused by the
pandemic
and how they're become so exasperated
with the uncertainty that exists today
so we'll start off with the first leg
justat to ask a question is
representative
Tucker yes uh my question is directed to
Mr
White uh I visited your plant two or
three times and uh it's very very
impressive and it's an enormous asset to
the North country I'm wondering whether
you're finding that young
people uh really understand
manufacturing and find the idea of
working uh at a factory appealing or
whether there's a problem with
attracting younger workers and what we
can do to help you with that if
anything I think that's a a great
question um from my back history I'm a
former teacher
and uh we we in this company have
reached out to the local communities to
try to educate schools and their
students so what potential positions are
available in facility like new and wire
whether would be accounting or
engineering or production or whatever it
may be and and I for one I feel that the
the greatest asset that we have is our
young
people uh I remember when I was young uh
older people would say I would never
make it your generation's not uh work
ethic isn't good enough and all that and
and I I prove I guess most of us proved
them wrong and and now you hear the same
thing from people in our generation
saying the same thing about younger
generation I don't see that I see the
young people coming out of schools in
this area uh are very capable
and as long as they they're educated
potential is there and we have hired a
lot of young people have worked out
great the work ethic is good the
capabilities with computers are far
superior to mine and we have a
tremendous amount of computerization in
our company and and I for one feel very
confident that young people today
particularly will go into manufactur and
do a great
job so um again the challenge is for
comp like Lisbon in Newland wire is is
our model is very simple we want to keep
our best here for a long period of time
some of our best students in the local
area whether it be Woodsville Lisbon
Littleton profile whatever we're we're
going to school at un or a BC or WPI or
RIT and never coming
back we have made a priority that we
hire somewhere between 20 and 25
college students per summer to try them
on one I call them try them on we want
to see what work ethic what capability
they might be to become a long-term
employee at no England wi and it's
worked out great we hired we fired we
HED four or five people college students
last year for that so again I probably a
long answer but U I'm all for young
people and and we can attract people
from the production level all the way up
to an engineering level as long as you
communicate you educate and you provide
them a path to successfully make
themselves
successful oh thank you very much okay
Senator
guer thank you Mr chairman thank you
gentlemen all for your fine
presentations uh my questions are two
first uh uh specifically to our
manufacturing uh person Val um and to
all of you do you
anticipate
uh Federal possible federal tax uh
policy changes
impacting uh your taxes in New Hampshire
your contributions to our tax base
question uh I don't see anything Federal
level having much of an impact on on uh
on us my size company um you know I take
advantage of the various tax credits and
whatever that are there I don't see uh
anything on the horizon that would have
a major impact on us so everything that
we we do in terms of investment um and
trying to move our company forward is
based on our markets not so much on uh
federal tax or or other other types of
policies uh things like the you know
minimum
wage that could be a problem as as
Cheryl was saying I mean we we pay a
starting person with almost no
experience $16 an hour people coming in
with experience maybe 17 or 18 that's a
$10 difference right now between minimum
wage and what we pay that's a that's a
lot of incentive to work here if someone
can make 15 bucks an hour of flipping
burgers or you know working in a in an
environment where they really have to
you know put effort in and think about
what they're doing for a $2 or $3 an
hour difference hey I'm I'm going to
lose employees real fast I mean there's
just no there's no incentive for anyone
to want to try to learn a trade when the
differential between a base pay for a
low value job like a flipping a burger
is going to pay almost what I can pay
and I I'm not in a market where I have
that kind of value in my product that I
can raise my differential back to five
or $10 doll an hour I mean I'm I'm
basically breaking even right
now unless the whole country went up and
I could raise my prices and not not uh
be affected by it um you know
differential raises in in minimum wage
you know could kill companies like mine
we we just don't have we're not making
turban blades that sell for thousands of
dollars where I can afford an extra
couple dollars an hour in labor we we
just don't have that we're we're right
at the razor's Edge right now if I could
pay people more I would do so but I I
have to balance out between what I can
pay and what the company can afford uh
to to keep itself alive so those are the
sorts of things that we we we worry
about thank you uh second does Cheryl or
Tom want to respond to
that from New England standpoint our
stting wages are anywhere between $18
and 20 $20 per hour so the what the
federates do
has basically no impact U from a state
level um we're very much involved with
the R&D tax our company is based on
Specialty Products that um requires a
lot of investment into R&D and and doing
things that so that may have an impact
but uh in general um I I don't feel that
whatever the federal government does is
going to have a significant impact on on
cherl you're M
muted you'll have to unmute yourself
Cheryl sorry about that um I I think Val
said it said it um perfectly about the
concern with the minimum wage I mean
only one only 1% of the of the of the
workforce is at minimum wage here in New
Hampshire anyways um you know I have
heard from some members that you know
the incre the potential increase in
taxes that are coming out of Washington
may have some employes ERS um look at
you know holding off on Capital
expenditures uh from a from a cash
perspective um but I don't think it will
have any impact on any tax base here in
New Hampshire um you know I don't think
it will have any impact on um you know
Staffing here in New Hampshire because
the problem is we can't hire hire
enough um Senator last coming and we've
actually done the opposite this is one
last comment we've actually increased
our uh expenditure in capital
investment we we felt strongly that um
in times of downturn was time to
invest so we've done the same we've
invested about uh four and a half to
five million dollar worth of equipment
um this past year in
2020 to do exactly what you're talking
about Val to try to improved capacity
improved efficiencies and whatever which
uh again um we at one point point we're
about 430 employees about 400 we we
haven't laid anybody off it's mostly
through attrition and retirement but
we've actually will be able to I think
produce $80 million worth of sales in
investment Senator gerer your second
party thank you Mr chairman I know this
is of interest to you as well uh do any
of your businesses utilize any New
Hampshire business tax credits I heard
R&D mentioned if so uh will you increase
your use this year because of the covid
pandemic uh or will it remain the same
or
decrease so we've we've been using the
R&D tax credit since its
Inception um we pretty much have R&D
going on all the time again as a
contract manufacturer every new piece of
business that I get is is an R&D project
we have to develop a process do
everything else um I don't don't see us
increasing it uh because it's really
driven by um you know the level of
business we have if we don't have a lot
of new business uh there's not as much
but what we're doing along with that
effort to uh in increase our equipment's
capability with capital Investments is
we're spending a lot more time refining
the processes that we have right now
trying to get time out of them to get
our our efficiencies up because we don't
see a lot of Topline uh growth you know
we're not going to see our sales
increase a lot so the only way we're
going to survive is to get the cost out
of our business so that means um you
know new equipment you know I I just
replaced a 30y old piece of equipment
with a brand new uh machine and we're
we're trying to add new machines as as
as we can afford to do that but at the
same time we're spending time on those
improvements all that becomes part of
R&D so the R&D tax credit for us is is a
critical uh part of our business so so
we're really you know concerned when we
hear you know talk about reducing or
eliminating the R&D tax credit because
it's it's so critical to a business like
grow we continue we will continue to use
at the same level or potentially
increase relative to what Cheryl was
saying about the company that she does
we have consciously uh vertically
integrated our company to be less
reliant on other
people uh it was kind of the we we took
the the opposite route of what most
people were telling us to do in the late
1990s and early 2000s and said we're
going to be our supplier for ourselves
as much as we possibly can and and
that's where the growth has come from
our number of people as well as our
Technologies because as we continue to
grow as a company that R&D tax is
absolutely imp comperative because we're
investing a significant amount of money
to improve our capabilities in the
materials we're making and honestly we
have had zero problems getting product
from our suppliers we've been very
fortunate we've had zero problems and uh
We've also tried to make sure that we
have at least two suppliers for every
product we get which we're not always
successful there but we've tried so
that's where New England's
experience Cheryl great yeah we we as
the Lawson group personally don't don't
utilize any tax credit you know
advantages here within the company and
Val and Tom can speak to it better than
I can uh you know on behalf of our
membership good thank you okay the next
Bron thank you Norm um thank you
everyone for your presentations so I
think the two companies that we heard
from uh that are manufacturers
uh Tom and U and Val
companies typify New Hampshire kind of
manufacturing where it's really where no
no uh uh consumer product type companies
no brand names come out of our state uh
with a few exceptions no Apple computer
no Ford motor Etc so first I want maybe
Dave can touch on this for for the
committee that these These are really
these two companies really tyfy the kind
of even the larger ones uh larger
manufacturers seem to fit in this
category but my question for after that
for Tom and for Val is how how much of
your sales is are in State versus out of
state so Dave you want to take it first
and then yeah I'll just respond to the
part of your question about what type of
manufacturing takes place here and um
there are some manufacturers that
manufacture products that consumer
products that that are made here but for
the most part the vast majority of
Manufacturers or what we would call
component manufacturers they make things
that are sent to other manufacturers
around the country or around the world
to uh use in their products um and you
know while while I'm guess on that point
that's what makes the R&D tax credit so
critical for the manufacturers in in
this state is there having to develop
oftentimes these new components and
these new parts it's what Val does
almost every day of of of his work at
graphic cast um so it's just it's you
know I'm appreciate uh Senator G asking
about that because it does illustrate a
really important and well-used uh
Economic Development incentive here in
New
Hampshire talking about our customer
base I have about 70 companies that we
make product for only one of them is in
New Hampshire everyone else is some
other state thanks
pal
Tom about 5% of our sales is is in
Hampshire you say five about 5% um but
the the main supplier for one of our raw
materials is also an Hampshire company
you okay
um next is from Jordan represent
urle uh thank you for taking my uh
question the comment that was made I
believe it was um by um Mr zanchuck
regarding the minimum wage I thought
thought was telling where if you have a
a set base for a McDonald's worker of
$15 an hour that means that for you to
compete you're going to have and you're
doubling the minimum wage now so you
essentially would have to double
your base rate your entry rate wage and
that would mean then that you would have
to raise your prices as well and that I
think would apply across the board
to the entire uh
manufacturing
spectrum that would be that your your
comment Mr zanj I thought was very
cogent the other part about that is
though but if you're raising your cost
and I'm buying it that means that I have
to raise my cost for the product that
I'm manufacturing which means the costs
go up so the effect of a minimum wage
raise
is doesn't
exist is that analysis basically correct
from your point of view yeah it is it is
from mine because you know if if
everything went up you know 10% um you
know then relatively everything is still
in the same proportion I mean in the end
you know a
job
pays what it's worth and the and the
value that it produces for the for the
company that's employing that
person you know if if the value isn't
there you you can't pay them more money
it just it's just it it's not
supportable uh economically that's why I
mentioned about you know the Val the
intrinsic value of the product that we
sell I mean we we have some parts that
we sell here for three or4 dollars a
piece the most expensive part we sell is
about
120 you know we we make a a certain
margin um you know between what we pay
our employees and the benefits and
everything else that goes along with
that if at the end of the year you know
we have 2% or 3% on the bottom line
that's that's a lot um you know for a
small company so you know we become an
engine to keep 21 people and their
family
you know fed and housed and and you know
we have a little left over and as an
ESOP company as well you know that helps
our employees but there's really not not
much there uh at the end of the day
between what we have to do um if we were
in a market where we had the ability to
pay more right now I'd be paying it
because I um you know I'm me in the
competitive employment Market here in in
the madog region I have New Hampshire
ball bearings on one side of me with 800
employees I have milipore on the other
side trying to hire 300 people I mean
they're all within three miles of where
I am so I have to pay competitive wages
and have competitive benefits just to
try to get people in the door um so you
know it's a it's a real struggle trying
to you know offer enough money to get
people in and also being able to to to
pay them and it's it's driven by our
sort of Market wages for what we do do
here plus the general economy um any any
disruption to that that is that is
totally arbitrary and not reflective of
economic value generated by people is is
just going to disrupt the whole the
whole uh the balance there so there
there has to be a reason uh and an
economic value to to increasing wages I
I just can't go out and in raise my
prices 25 or 30% without having you know
somebody in another part of the country
outbid me and I end up losing the
business and then what happens is 21
people are out of a job so I mean it
sense it's my opinion that um by raising
the the federal middle wage is going to
negatively
impact the market that is most affected
by Co you're talking about restaurants
you're talking about hotels and hos
ability hospitality and stuff like that
that's the labor market that's been
affected by most by CO as far as I can
see and when you raise the minimum wage
to $15 an
hour you're going to put more and more
companies or hotels or restaurants out
of business because of it I'm a big
believer in open market you pay for what
you can pay for and if you're not you're
paying lower than somebody else then you
may not get an
employee right let let the open market
determine what the wages are and that's
just my opinion
Cheryl I I I concur they they they
they've said it they've said it the best
anything I would say would be would be
completely
redundant okay next question from
representative
Aly thank you I'm not going to get into
the minimum wage but
on the situation was the same back in 20
years ago 30 40 years ago I guess it was
on but our minimum wage hasn't changed
so um and and the federal government and
the state governments have to make up
for that in the lower income groups so
uh it's a very difficult problem I agree
but what I wanted to ask you about was
there is a
federal uh research and development tax
credit which when we put in the federal
uh the state tax credit I was
instrumental in that um
at a much lower level than it is now on
was a great deal higher than the one
coming from New Hampshire what
percentage of of the
total research and development tax
credit that you get which is critical to
your development what percentage of that
is actually the the New Hampshire tax
credit um at least in our in our case
the New Hampshire credits well the the
amount that we get has varied when we
first started taking the credit we were
getting somewhere on the order of like
15 or 177% of whatever we put in uh for
a credit because it had to be you know
was limited by the the million dollars
or $2 millionar right now we're getting
about 85 or 90% of what we put in but um
the New Hampshire portion of the the
total R&D tax credit that we get Federal
plus New Hampshire I think New Hampshire
and I have to look at the numbers but
it's probably like a 25% or so I mean
it's the the federal the federal impact
is there's no limit to it um and at the
at the New Hampshire level chance I mean
based on the the number of of companies
that have put in we're relatively close
to being able to um you know offer a
credit equal to the amount that's been
asked for I know there's some
restrictions on the in the actual amount
and we've certainly seen it over the
years as we've gone from 1 million to2
million to $7 million credit we've
gotten closer to 100% of what we have
put in for um and and applying for the
New Hampshire Credit is is fairly
straightforward because it uses the
Federal Form so if you're going to apply
for the federal R&D tax credit the the
time it takes you to add the New
Hampshire Credit on top of that is
minimal so it is a very simple system to
use um but it doesn't you know quite
have as much of an impact as as the
Federal Credit
does Tom yes I I don't have the numbers
but I can certainly get those for you
but um and if you'd like I would do the
research for you I don't have the
numbers to at the tip of my
tongue I would love love to see that
thank you because uh the 7 million is a
uh drag on our budget for other things
that you need and we need um but and
I've been worried that it would be going
up increasingly as more and more big
businesses use it it was structured so
that it would work better for the small
businesses
originally okay the next question is
amander
gor gorg gorg
okay um I want to thank you all so much
uh for uh giving a very realistic
perspective on what's Happening I too am
a small business owner on the Sea Coast
and I'm curious as we're talking about
wages I know it's very different
throughout the state and we've gotten a
lot of Statistics um over the past day
and a half
and you know where our income lies
throughout you know where our um poorest
people are where our more wealthier
people are and I'm curious especially
because you guys are on the other side
of the state how much as a range do you
actually pay your employees
if you're comfortable in saying
this so in our case you know starting
employees about 16 the most experienced
person on the floor is probably getting
24 and right now uh we're operating on
an overtime situation so uh you know
they're adding another 10 hours a week
at time and a half so um you know we
have people that are making 50 to 60,000
a year you know as Factory workers with
um you know us paying 70% of the health
insurance premium and having an ESOP
plan in place and everything else so um
you know and we've we've checked against
you know the the market here looking at
the state's uh you know input as to
average wages for different types of
jobs and different geographies so we try
to be you know slightly above the the
average wage for the type of work that
we have here so that we can be a little
bit more competitive in in getting the
people joh in terms of the hourly I
mentioned before hourly typically start
and use a direct labor people anywhere
between 18 and $20 an hour to
start as well but we have direct labor
people making 21 $22 an hour we have a
graded system that we bring in a third
party to review our jobs so that uh and
we also look at Regal um values what
people are paying for an hourly job in
say Burlington or nashv whatever we want
to be as a company the the company of
choice so we try to typically pay more
than any of our competition we we also
have course exempt employees that could
be making up to 60 70 80 $90,000 a year
depending on where they are whether
they're Engineers or whatever they may
be because again we have a wide spectrum
of type of jobs this type of company
yeah even in my small company of 21
people I have salaried employees making
70 80,000 a year
so and I can tell you here um at our
organization um everyone is you know
everyone we don't have hourly hourly
folks they're all exempt and you know
they range from coming in you know
beginning 34 $35,000 a year up to as
high as Val had said you know 75 $80,000
a year not you know non- senior level
people but just you know coming in and
most of our our rates you know as as um
Tom has said you know they're
market-based you know what do I need to
pay to have the best of the best
compared to my competition who's trying
to take the people from me right I'm not
gonna let a minimum wage drive that I'm
gonna I'm gonna let them the market
drives that no different than what you'd
sell your product for yeah and for our
our our hourly wage people you can
probably add five dollar an hour for
benefits and taxes and things that we
have to pay uh for every so effective
cost of some somebody on the shop floor
could be you know 22 to $30 an hour just
on the benefits plus salary yeah if you
if you add yeah if you add that into our
our wage package as well Val yes correct
because we as as the lossing group we
pay 100% of our employees health
insurance you know we pay uh we
contribute 5% for a 401k we do a profit
sharing every year to the extent we're
able to so I mean that you you can add
15 to 20% just on you know additional
benefits you know over and and we we
have to do that I mean I pay more in uh
health insurance premium for my
employees than the profit of my company
so absolutely so so the health insurance
premium exceeds the the bottom line
profit at the end of the year I mean
last year 2019 we made about
$330,000 and I paid out $90,000 in
Insurance health insurance premiums so
you know the the the cost of for us to
run our businesses to do all the things
we need to do uh insurances benefits
competitive wages um it's it's it's
quite quite high it's quite High plus I
have all the fixed expenses I have you
know electricity and equipment and you
know all the you know leases and things
I pay on equipment so it it uh you know
we're looking upwards of 55 $60 an hour
for every person on the floor of of
total cost to support that person so I
you know we try to price our our our
product at about you know $100 per hour
value so that the difference of 40 then
pays for the the non-manufacturing
people the office people the sales
people the engineers and everything else
and at the end of the day you know if we
have 3% left over on the bottom line
we've had a successful
year Dave do you have anything want to
say to wrap it up no uh just uh greatly
appreciate the opportunity to talk to
you a little about uh what's going on in
New New Hampshire's manufacturing
environment and I think you've heard
both uh some good news but also some uh
challenges ahead for 2021 and want to
encourage any committee members if you
are interested in talking to an employer
or manufacturer in your from your
District just give me a call and I'll
try and match you up thank you Mr
chair this has been very very helpful to
us and we appreciate the
Cheryl and Tom coming in explaining
their business and their
challenges and thank you our pleasure
thank you pleasure thanks for the
opportunity for the U
committee we can all when I'm through
you can all mute yourself and mute your
video and we'll start again at
1:00 and at 1 o'l we'll be listening to
Ben fr Ross who managing direct the New
Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority and then after that we'll talk
to Patricia Tilly deputy director
division of Public Health Services
Department of Health and Human Services
primarily discussing the the
pandemic all right I'll see we'll see
you back at one o'clock thank you so I
just mute your your v um audio and your
video
there this is chisay um Jen is on a
phone call so she's unable to talk at
the moment yeah I just noticed down on
the mute button it says that if you hit
your space bar you can unmute real quick
maybe that should be another uh little
announcement that can can be made that's
just a suggestion no you're absolutely
correct that is one way that if you
wanted to speak temporarily to say ask a
question you can push that down and it
will unmute you and then once you let it
go you'll be muted again yeah no problem
bye
there I am represent major um would you
get a hold of U Jen and ask her if she
could get a hold of of
uh Joe gimmel to have them provide the
slides that the that Jeffrey used yep I
could do that but probably Let's try her
and if that's an issue then I I will I
will do that sounds good rebon major
yeah we'll follow up and see if we can
get them and either she or myself will
let you know if there's any issues with
welcome
Susan hi I'm sorry yesterday I didn't
understand I thought you were going
straight through 12
o'clock you got to see the
inauguration well no I missed the out
swearing but I've recorded major I just
wanted to let you know that uh Mr Ben
Frost is in attendance and I've moved
him into the panelist list so that he
can um just be prepared for when you
introduce him okay thank
you
[Music]
for
start you can begin when you're
ready
okay since we didn't adjourn the meeting
I don't have to read the entrance all
over so um we're privileged to have uh
Mr Ben
Frost who was the managing director of
policy and public affairs the New
Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority where he manages legisl
legislative initiatives Communications
research and strategic planning and also
serves as the internal legal council he
will discuss the state's housing market
thank you chairman major and uh good
afternoon to you all it's um I think the
first time I've appeared before either a
house or a senate committee um in this
manner um although I've been testifying
before your committees for an awfully
long time couple decades it seems It's a
new way of doing
things it is um and we we're all keeping
safe and that's a good thing I
suppose um so our executive director
Dean Kristen uh very much wish wishes he
could be here with you today but he uh
has U Board of director meetings uh that
he's attending to so um he has to be
there and so I I get the pleasure of um
filling in his shoes today and what what
you've asked me to do is to um talk
about the the housing market in New
Hampshire and some of the issues related
to the housing market so I've prepared a
um a PowerPoint presentation which I've
shared with Jen and I'm going to share
that share my screen with you now and I
believe you can see
that it looks like it's coming up there
it is there it is
okay um so just first off for those of
you who are perhaps unfamiliar with New
Hampshire housing uh we're not a state
agency but we are created by state
statutes uh we were created by the
legislature in 1981 as a a
self-sustaining public corporation uh so
we're
an instrumentality that
uh fulfills important governmental
functions as defined by the legislature
we have a nine member board of directors
who are appointed by governor and
Council and there's our mission which
you know basically is to help ensure
that everyone in the state has a a safe
decent and affordable place to live and
we do that by administering a variety of
different programs uh ranging from
rental assistance uh directly provided
to tenants uh or through
landlords providing um assisting with
home
ownership and upwards of 2,000
households every year we assist uh we
Finance we don't build housing uh we
don't own housing but we Finance multif
family uh rental construction uh and we
do something on the order of 500 to a
th000 units a year and we oversee a
portfolio of uh 400 projects totaling
about 15,000 units we also do uh a lot
of research on the housing market and
really that's that's why I'm here that's
the the group that I head at New
Hampshire Housing and so we provide uh
research and technical assistance to uh
the public and to you the legislature uh
to help you make uh informed decisions
on the housing market over our history
uh We've helped more than 50,000 New
Hampshire families purchase homes we've
created um 15,000 multif family rental
housing units um and provide you know
direct assistance to tens of thousands
of households and here's some some of
the data from from this year this past
year
fy2020 so we're we're an active
organization um and we have an impact on
the N Hampshire uh economy on something
on the order of $700 million uh every
year uh and so that's uh we're we're
we're an important part of uh what goes
on in the real estate market in New
Hampshire and it's a mission that we
take very
seriously um now with regard to the the
housing market I'll I'll talk about the
rental market um a little later on but I
want to start with the discussion about
uh the the purchase market and what's
going on there and well what is going on
there that's a really good question um
it we we read the headlines and the the
newspapers and the my goodness the the
market is is redh hot
um a a colleague of mine in our home
ownership Vision um I like to say that
uh uh that November is the new June uh
and typically speaking we would see uh
prices falling off in the winter months
starting in in know October November
because people just weren't purchasing
there wasn't a lot of demand they're
they're going up now not going down uh
and and there's a lot of reasons this
might be happening but and we'll take a
look at a couple of those but you can
see that uh the November figures are up
177% over November of
2019 uh December figures just came out
and it's pretty much the same thing up
up about 177% um between December 2020
and December 2019 and that's the that's
the median sales price of a single
family home in New Hampshire um it's U
the market is different it's behaving
differently than it has uh traditionally
and we're fascinated to figure figure
out why that is well part of the issue
is um you know the it's it is a classic
supply and demand issue uh listings are
down substantially and this is
particularly uh impacting the the lower
end of the market and by lower end I
mean U Homes that sell for $300,000 or
less uh and for the first time in an
awfully long time that inventory has has
fallen
below um uh the the the uh homes that
are available above
$300,000 now part of that's we we're not
controlling for inflation here so that
might yield a a slightly different um
graph but the fact is uh that the the
price the homes available on the market
that are listed on the market at below
$300,000 are very few and far in between
they're hard to find and that has an
impact on in particular first-time home
buyers who haven't developed Equity
they're not moving up they're trying to
get the the foothold into uh the
purchase market and it is really really
do um closed sales Well yeah if you if
you look at the way things have been
over the past couple years again we
would see the sales dropping off in the
winter months that is not happening now
even though the inventory is low sales
are still very high uh it's kind of a
conundrum where that that has has
implications on the prices uh so again
demand um the amount of time that a a
house might spend on the market now I've
I've lived in a number of different
homes and sold them from time to time as
I've moved from place to place sometimes
I've been really lucky and and sold it
one house I sold the day before it came
on the market but that's really what's
happening right now um a lot of homes
are being scooped up as soon as they
come on the market Market the average
right now is uh under one month uh which
fast this is um the the months to absorb
inventory is a um kind of an industry
standard way of looking at the inventory
uh and this is the uh the amount of time
it would take to sell the current
inventory at the preceding 12 months
pace of sale
now recognize that the first half of
2020 was kind of slow for obvious
reasons but then starting the the middle
of the summer really picked up fast so
if we were to look at the current um
pace of sales it would be substantially
less than what's shown here it would be
less than uh 9/10 of a month uh for
those properties under 300,000 less than
1.2 months for the properties for all
properties um this is uh
it's um it's really shocking what's
market and what's driving this interest
rates this is the principal driver there
are other factors too but the very low
interest rates that we're facing the
historically low interest rates that
have that consumers have available to
them is what is driving uh the market
right now U so you see this interest
rate at at 2.68 and this is a national
survey done by Freddy Mack um this is
the lowest it has been since Freddy Mack
started doing this in
1971 it's really low and you might have
heard um fed chairman Jerome Powell last
week say um that uh the FED is not
exiting this strategy anytime soon so
the the federal funds rate is close to
zero it's going to stay there for the
foreseeable future until conditions
I want to take a moment to talk about
foreclosures because this has been in
our minds for a long time since the the
Great Recession and the Foreclosure
crisis that so many families in New
Hampshire been nationally faced um you
during the the four years uh dur of the
technically speaking the recession was a
a you know like 12 14 months but uh the
the four years in and around the
recession uh roughly 20,000 New
Hampshire families lost their homes to
we've seen this trend going down uh
slowly over time as the economy has
improved uh as people's employment and
income situations have improved as
people have gotten their their financial
feet under them more firmly uh we've
seen a drop off in in
foreclosures um even and and right now
things are very different because we
have the option of uh forbearance for
anyone who has a federally backed
mortgage and in earlier in the year
there was the Foreclosure moratorium U
that that also had a significant impact
on what was going on here obviously uh
prior to that we would have estimated uh
we did estimate that we expected to see
um something on the order of 600
foreclosures in New Hampshire uh in
20120 uh it turns out and this is U not
complete data for the year but turn out
we'll be looking at something on the
order of 250 or
275 when we compile those data um but
the you know this is the the important
thing to consider here is uh this is
really a sell's market so there's really
not a good reason for anyone to be uh
faced with the prospect of foreclosure
if you have to sell your house you
should be able to sell your house in
this market what we're seeing is that
most of the the foreclosures that are
going on right now the few that are
happening are of properties that have
been abandoned so the owners have simply
left and they've they've turned it over
to the bank to deal with um it may also
be the case where uh we're seeing some
level of foreclosures uh in properties
that don't have Federal backing uh and
so so that aren't backed by FHA or Fanny
or Freddy or the VA um and and that and
that's about 30% of the
um First Mortgage Market in New
Hampshire uh and a lot of those may be
manufactured housing as well because
they're most of them are not eligible
for federally backed mortgages um that
may change in the future but that's the
situation
now
um I have read for the past several
months since the summertime uh countless
articles headlines uh statements from
Realtors and journalists and reporters
it's the Massachusetts buyers that are
driving the market in New
Hampshire and so we started looking at
these data and um you know over the past
five years roughly three qus of all
purchasers in New Hampshire came from
New Hampshire someplace in New Hampshire
uh 15% over that period came from
Massachusetts and every other state
contributed uh
about 1% or less for a total of 100% now
compare the the annual data over the
past five years and my question to you
is is this a flood of home buyers from
Massachusetts I don't think so there's
been an uptick certainly in the number
of the the proportion of buyers from
Massachusetts but it's certainly not a
flood uh this is and the the 2020 data
are through uh mid October um and so
we'll we'll continue to Analyze This but
I don't really expect this to tr to
change dramatically uh what's what's
going on here it's not so much the
Massachusetts buyers although they may
have an impact on the higher end of the
market so there may be some price
stratification going on here where the
buyers from Massachusetts are competing
more for the um the higher end housing
and less for the lower end housing
really I think what the the greater
impact on New Hampshire is is not in the
purchase of homes by people from out of
state but the occupancy of those homes
by people who already own their second
homes they may be working in in Metro
Boston and they decide you know uh March
comes around the pandemic strikes and
they say well we're pulling the family
put taking the kids out where they're
learning remotely anyway taking the kids
to go to our Lake home on on
winaki and and and I think that that is
having an impact and early on we heard
from people in the North Country um you
know there are people here now who
aren't normally here and they were
saying that in March April May those are
the people who vacation up north um
don't live up North but they're living
up north right now and that definitely
does have an impact on New Hampshire but
not so much an impact on the home buying
market now let me turn to um the
resident the rental market and take a
few
take a a look at
that and most of the data that I have
here comes from our New Hampshire
housing's residential rental cost survey
which we do every year we survey uh
landlords uh and the the data set is
about 20,000 units we filter out some
anomalous figures and control for size
uh so we use a sample of about uh 12,000
units so it's a very robust survey uh
and really the best source of rental um
data that we have from any any any
source and what you see in the rental uh
price trends is this slow steady
inexurable it seems Trend upward um and
if we were to go back farther in time uh
through the Great Recession back into
the early 2000s back into the mid 90s
you would see this steady trend of price
increases so even during the Great
Recession and you think about that well
you know I said earlier you know roughly
20,000 New Hampshire families lost their
homes to foreclosure a good number of
those went into the renter market so
that that um uh had a significant impact
on price and
availability
um so you see this this ongoing Trend
and part of this is reflected to uh
geographically you know the the four uh
Southeastern counties in the state it's
where the bulk of the people live it's
where the bulk of the housing units are
and that's where the the bulk of the
cost is so Rockingham straford marac and
Hillsboro counties and you see the uh
the change in prices occurring there uh
pretty substantially you know 20 28%
increase over five years um in
Rockingham County 26% in hillsbor County
but go up to Coos County too uh at 12
and a half percent increase that's a
pretty healthy increase and it's a good
for the property owners uh tougher for
the rent
certainly um it it said you know Coos
County obviously has the lowest median
rental cost of any county in the state
and it's often said well that makes it
the most
affordable well in comparison to
Statewide incomes yeah it is but if
you're looking at the incomes of the
people who live in each County coas
county is actually the least affordable
county in the state uh housing problems
exist all over the the
state um I also would want to point out
Grafton county is uh very much a tale of
two maybe three counties uh because you
have Handover and Levan in the southwest
corner of the of the county which are
really driving a local economy there a
local housing market and increase
overall the the median and uh that we
see represented here elsewhere in
Grafton County uh the rents would be
locations um a another aspect of the
rental market is the vacancy rates and
we consider a you know a 5% vacancy rate
to be something where the market is
balanced between the interests of the
landlords and the tenants uh 3% is
pretty much a turnover measure it's the
time that a landlord has to take to
prepare a unit for a new tenant after an
old one moves
out and you look for the past seven
years we've had a Statewide vacancy rate
of below
3% uh this is not an indicator of a
healthy rental market uh it's an
indication that uh Supply is is
demand uh the increase that we see
between 2019 and 2020 of 1% from8 to 1.8
that's perhaps a good sign it may be an
anomalous Trend uh but we'll we'll take
it as good news and and and maybe this
is attributable to the uh the multif
family construction that's been going on
in places like um you know London Derry
and in the Sea
Coast that remains to be
seen and if you look at the vacancy
rates by County you see that um they're
low everywhere uh there's there's no
exception to this case and in comparison
to uh the the region the Northeast
region and the United States as a whole
our uh vacancy rates are way below uh
averages and this all has U an impact on
affordability um if you're making the
median income of the state you know so
82,000 for a family of three you can
afford pretty much everything that's on
the market at a 30% cost burden but if
you're making only half the median uh
for
,000 you can't afford a whole lot you
can afford 11% of what's on the market
and if you're making
$25,000 you can't afford just about
anything that's on the market uh and
recognize that as the the less money you
make um that that 30% consumes uh
relatively more uh because you have less
actual money left after your rent has
been paid there's a common expression
now in in um in some Circles of
Advocates and and academics uh that the
rent eats first uh so for people who um
are faced with the the the prospect well
I'm going to pay my rent or am I going
to pay my auto insurance or make that
auto repair I'm GNA pay the rent first
uh and then whatever is left after that
goes to the auto insurance the health
insurance the medical bills the
prescriptions food for your
kids
so um if if the demand is so high and um
why aren't Builders building well you
can see the builders really are not
building at anywhere near the pace that
they had been before the black line is
single family homes the the brown line
is multif family and this is units U
being
permitted um so a 10 unit multif family
uh project would be counted as 10 units
uh on this graph uh and we just haven't
recovered the market has not recovered
the development Market has not recovered
since the Great Recession um for a
variety of reasons um which we're still
exploring this really is fundamentally a
question of supply and demand the
question is why why aren't Builders
building well my my colleague here at
New Hampshire housing George Regan likes
to cite the the five L's that he calls
as he calls them and some of these we
can we can have some influence over
others we can't influence so much we
can't influence the cost of lumber and
other other construction materials we
can't really influence Supply chains
that much um we can influence somewhat
more uh Workforce availability through
uh training programs and the like or um
Financial incentives maybe to certain
industries but there's there's just so
much we can do there as well Banks Banks
are ready to lend uh to any developer ER
who's willing to have taken the risk uh
banks are will are willing to lend for
projects that are ready to go uh and
that's really the the issue uh
developers have to take the risk upfront
before they can get Bank financing and I
I'll tell you that's not a business I
would want to be in I don't I I don't
have that appetite for risk that uh that
developers do um and that and it is a a
significant risk for any developer to
pursue uh a project it may cost several
$1,000 just to get through the
permitting process before they even get
to bank financing to
build um so what's the risk here well
land costs yeah can can we control the
market no or can
we regulatory practices in particular at
the local level do have a significant
impact on the cost of land uh and so to
the degree we want to influence costs of
land and reduce developers risk and
increase the supply of housing we have
to deal with in particular local
regulatory
practices and it's both zoning and
subdivision regulations and site plan
regulations and how they are implemented
by the boards that do
this so just to summarize all of this we
have a couple of uh really important
issues very high demand that's fueled by
interest rates um and I didn't cover it
here but there is some evidence of more
conservative consumer Behavior after the
Great Recession not and I know you got a
presentation this morning from Phil slon
and he talked about still families not
saving but their credit scores on
average are a lot better now than they
were uh during the Great Recession or
after the Great Recession they have
improved um people seem to have learned
some better behaviors on average uh and
that puts them in a better position to
be able to buy a home and we're seeing
some evidence of that now but we're also
likely to see a what we're calling a
k-shaped recovery people on the higher
end of the income Spectrum likely to do
okay people lower down less likely to do
okay we also have this constrained
Supply as a as a significant issue uh
underproduction for a long time has left
us with a deficit we estimate to be uh
20,000 units Statewide just to meet
current demand forget about future
growth this is just to bring balance
back to the purchase and Rental markets
we would need another 20,000 units and
here are the the contri contributing
factors which I've already talked about
um the
implications uh chairman major you you
mentioned yesterday in in one of the
presentations I was listening to if we
if we don't have housing we can't get
workers um that that's really a a
fundamental problem that we face right
now the housing Supply is having a
negative impact on economic growth it's
a constraint to economic growth
and you we know how much we need to grow
our economy uh to to among other things
make lives better but also uh to to fund
the state's budget um I focus in
particular on the um the rental market
uh we need to have a really what I would
call a fluid rental market uh because it
helps with labor Mobility it provides an
opportunity for people to move into a
town before they decide what they want
to buy where they want to buy you get a
job um say you get aob two job offers
one in um in Lebanon and one somewhere
in Ohio um and you look at the housing
market in Lebanon and you say well I I
can't even afford a place to rent I'm G
to take that job in Ohio and you got a
20% raise without actually making any
more money uh and I've said this already
but the uh affordability issues that are
um propounded by this um lack of supply
has the greatest impact on people of
lower income it affects their stability
of housing it affects the their kids uh
and threatens them with homelessness
these are problems that we we have to
deal with um there I don't want to leave
it on on that dark note um so let me
just give you a couple of possible
solutions uh one uh the legislature has
already done and this is the uh
establishment of the housing appeals
board to make it easier for U people who
face adverse decisions Lo
to get a day in court uh using the same
legal standards uh that Superior Court
applies but doing it in a a faster more
efficient manner than the courts can do
uh the housing appeals board opened its
doors to appeals just last week um and
another one is um representative Joe
Alexander's uh bill which is a house
bill 586 this is a combination of two
bills that uh were making their way
through the legisl last year in fact one
of them had just come out of the the
house Ways and Means Committee with a
unanimous ought to pass with Amendment
uh recommendation um and both it looked
like we're going to proceed um and get
get adopted but then they they like so
many other worthy bills um fell victim
to covid uh representative Alexander has
combined those two bills in this one uh
piece of legislation which will go to
the house Municipal and County
government uh committee sometimes soon
so I look forward to seeing how that
works and I'll be happy to take any
questions and try to give some
answers well thank
you a you provided us a lot of good
information on our state of our
housing uh we do have at least three
hands up the first questioner is
brahney
R you have to unmute got it I got it
thanks thanks Norm uh great presentation
appreciate it uh back to the five L's I
like that the five L's um I think we
could do something about Labor we talked
about a bit yesterday in terms of
training and all that uh the laws we've
heard this in the past about uh
permitting and I've heard it directly
from Builders and uh drill depends on
your town it gets pretty complicated
what I what's a mystery to me is land I
mean land I know our land the dirt
itself is worth a lot especially in
Rockingham where I
am what's the hesitation what what's the
hold back with the land is it is it the
cost of the land or uh people unwilling
to sell their land um can you just
Enlighten us a little bit on
that well thank thanks representative I
this is a really good question it's not
there's not a simple answer to this but
the cost of land is uh part of the
development equation uh so you might uh
you might choose one parcel of land over
another if you're a developer um but
really the point I'm making here is that
um the cost of land does not exist in
isolation from other factors uh it is
influenced by other factors a good part
of it is simply market demand
so all other things being equal
including local regulation uh parcel of
land
in uh Rockingham County is going to be
more valuable and and therefore more
expensive to purchase than a parcel of
land in say Coos County uh that's just
the market um the question though is
what is the influence of local
regulation on the cost of land so you
might say you know I've heard some towns
saying well we're built
out according to your current
regulations yes you're built out but if
you if you're came up with different
regulations then there's tremendous
opportunity for additional development
uh and some towns might say well we
don't want that okay I get that that's
your choice but you you can't deny that
regulations don't have an impact on the
cost of land and that's that's really
the the point I'm making there okay
you representative
Ames thank you and thank you for that
great
presentation um so my question has to do
with the property tax the local property
tax and how it might affect uh oh the uh
the rental price the the the rent that's
charged in uh from town to town we know
that the property tax varies
enormously uh from town to town
so um you know they price in uh in
Claremont or uh in a number of towns
that I could site where the taxes are
very high
um is very different from the tax that's
uh that's going going to be paid by a
landlord in uh in uh Portsmouth or uh or
any number of towns uh at the other end
of the tax Spectrum so I'm just
wondering how that translates
into whether You' studied this issue of
how property taxes feed into the price
uh that has to be charged by a
landlord well we we've not studied it as
part of a comprehensive study um but we
we do study it with every project that
we underwrite so um when we're financing
the development of a u multif family um
housing project we very carefully under
write those projects for a period of 20
years and the property taxes do play an
important part of the development costs
as do operations and and other factors
um so you know it it does uh form part
of the the proforma if you if you will
of any development that we look at uh
and you're right uh that the property
taxes do vary substantially from one
Community to the next um but there also
sometimes uh counterveiling factors so
uh you used Claremont and Portsmouth as
as two examples well the um the taxes
relatively speaking paid on the property
in Portsmouth might be less than the
property paid in Claremont property in
claremont's going to cost you less at
the outset than the property in
Portsmouth so there there are there is
some some balance between those two
things uh one thing I would want to say
about um the property tax uh and this is
in particular with regard to um the
development of new housing uh and and
especially rental housing um it is often
cited by opponents to uh those projects
at the local level before planning board
or a zoning Board of adjustment well all
those kids that are going to come with
this development we've got to pay to
educate them um that's that is um there
is some uh mythology associated with
this argument because it's not really
based in fact um we we this is something
that we have studied in some detail in
fact we have a series of studies that
were done by Russ tibo a few years back
uh the most recent one I think was 2012
where we look at the the impact of new
residential construction on uh School
population and where we see the greatest
impact on school population is in
association with large single family
homes it's really related to bedrooms
and and the the the capacity of a home
to accommodate kids um smaller units
with fewer bedrooms tend as you might
expect to have fewer kids associated
with them and the type of construction
the type of of building also influences
the number of kids that are in those
units so a a a multiplex you know multif
family uh uh rental project with a bunch
of two-bedroom units is going to have on
average far fewer kids than your typical
single family home uh and do the math um
the the tax revenue you get from these
multif family projects is pretty
substantial and probably uh on average
outweighs that what you get from single
family homes and we have done some
additional analysis on that and that's
available on our
website okay
B before we go to the next one um you
mentioned rust tall r we were going to
have Russ make a presentation uh over
the last two days but he has a medical
issue right now and we'll have back
later
EXA um you didn't really mention what's
variation in buildable land between the
North and the South part of the state
because I know that where I where I'm
from and right next to massachusett
border if you have buildable piece of
land that's that's going to cost
$150,000 obviously you don't put a
$150,000 building on it you probably to
make it worthwhile it' be like 300,000
so now got a
$450,000 home so what is the range of
differences in buildable land cost
South chairman major we haven't looked
looked at that but that that would be
relatively uh simple exercise I think uh
to look at um you know available land
cost what's on the market for raw land
we could certainly uh pull some of that
data and and get that back to your
committee okay thanks happy to do that
um representative
alme thank you I'd just like to say
something about that from our section of
Grafton County which is in incredbly
expensive uh for our area and on we are
actually a kind of an
island um with difficulty of commuting
in Winter that is prob is considerably
worse I think than in the east and south
of the state but on a lot of our land is
subject to Major
wetness uh it's hilly it's Rocky
on there most of our our hilly areas get
enormous amounts of rain flowing down
and creating floods on and the
developers that come from outside which
is all of our developers at this point I
think maybe not um don't notice that
which is one reason that that the costs
come in a lot higher in the end if they
keep up with that um it's
a a problem with us being our Regulators
being considered uh uncooperative by
some developers they complain about it
but uh when they build we get
floods so on the the problem that I
wanted well what I wanted to ask about
was you mentioned the housing appeals
board you mentioned uh
1632 and the companion bill in Municipal
and County uh you did not mention the
five million added into the budget for
the first time in uh 15 years 20 years
um for the housing authority and when I
came to you last year while we were
doing the
then uh uh Griffith Alex and Alexander
bill on and asked you whether we could
take some of that five million to pay
for things that were in in that bill on
I was told that you really needed that
five million for the stuff you've got it
for so I presume that that's something
you want to see I'd love to see you keep
keeping that also but I'm worried about
the blank check that was in the bill
last term uh for building and and that
we cannot C calculate the cost of and on
how how it could get
budgeted
thanks thank you for that and and yes I
I didn't mention it in part because um
we generally leave the advocacy for
funding to others um we as an
institution of the state we uh we choose
not to go to the legislature asking for
money when when we are asked to uh we
happily testify on what we would do with
it if you the legislature chose to make
those
Appropriations um so that said we're
really grateful uh that the legislature
has allocated uh $5 million annually out
of the real estate transfer tax uh
revenues for the affordable housing fund
which is the state's affordable housing
trust fund uh administered by by New
Hampshire housing on behalf of the state
we use that for uh financing of multif
family rental housing
construction um and it is uh honestly
the the most flexible source of
financing that we have uh and to do U
financing of of housing
construction um it it is it is the
legislature's choice to do what it wants
with the revenues that it gets from the
sources it determines so the legislature
has chosen to do this with $5 million a
year um if if you chose to do something
else with that then that means we would
build we would Finance less housing
construction and that's that's the the
bottom line it it it is a linear
equation so U more money means more
housing less money means less housing um
and I you know I I I I won't address the
the priorities question because that's
really a political question uh for for
you all to address and is beyond my pay
grade
certainly okay I just like to point out
on that that your financing has been key
in getting an awful lot of housing for
the median income on down in the
last well forever but but there's been a
lot more of it this last time I
appreciate that representative Aly uh we
we use the affordable housing fund to
leverage other funds and The Leverage is
pretty substantial it ranges from uh
five times to 12 times depending upon
the project um and and in certain
circumstances it allows us to finance
projects that otherwise um would not
happen because they can't get financing
from other sources such as things that
we call special needs so housing for
people with developmental disabilities
or housing or substance use disorder U
people exiting um mental health
institutions uh there there's really not
much funding elsewhere uh for that kind
of housing uh and we use the affordable
housing fund for those purposes in
addition to you know uh plain van plain
vanilla run-of-the-mill uh affordable
housing for people who need
housing
any other
questions so I will thank you uh Ben Qui
presentation all right thanks very
much now has U Patricia Tilly shown up
uh yes she's here waiting oh
afternoon CH Tilly is the deputy
director of the division of Public
Health Services and the Department of
Health and Human Services she's going to
discuss the pandemic conditions in the
state and the status of vaccine
distribution great thank you so much for
inviting me here today thank you chair
thank you to The Honorable members of
the committee I'm going to take a moment
and share our screen I will turn off my
video while I'm talking just so you're
not distracted by me looking at my notes
and then I'll pop it back on when when
I'm done so let me turn off the video
and get this uh screen share done all
right
there we go I think we're up and ready
right now so thank you again for
inviting us here today to do this brief
update on our Public Health response to
covid-19 and our plans for vaccine
distribution we know that stopping a
pandemic requires all the tools that we
have available to us Granite Staters
have been wearing masks and social
distancing businesses have implemented
new policies and procedures healthcare
workers have heroically served on the
front lines caring for patients all of
this has helped reduce exposure but even
these measures are not enough um a
public health approach to preventing
mitigating and controlling this virus
requires us to use the full spectrum of
Public Health functions in resources we
start with our assessment roles and
collecting analyzing and using data to
make informed decisions critical to our
response has been the transparency of
this data that I hope that you have all
found on our new hampshire. goov covid
website and we finally assure that all
New Hampshire residents have Equitable
access to the services they need in the
case of covid that means safe places for
employment access to testing high
quality medic Medical Care and now
vaccine we um RSA 141 provides DHHS with
the authority to prevent control and
mitigate communicable diseases such as
the Corona virus because of the
unnecessary risk to health life and the
orderly workings of business education
and
government so let's jump into the data
then today is the
313th day of our public Public Health
Emergency that Governor sinunu declared
on March 13 2020 it is also the one-year
anniversary today of the first case of
Corona virus in the US that required
hospitalization there have been more
than 24 million cases of covid diagnosed
in the United States and over
400,000 deaths Co is among the leading
causes of death nationally and here at
home in New Hampshire comparatively New
Hampshire is doing better than many of
the states Across the Nation right now
in the average daily cases in the past
seven
days but that leads us to New Hampshire
data and you can see that we hit our
highest daily counts back in December
and early January our cumulative count
of total cases since the beginning of
the pandemic is more than 58,000 just
almost at
59,000 last night we announced that we
processed 877 new cases
334 cases specific to January
19th this is a decrease from the past
seven days which is good news to give
some context to these numbers back in
the summer we were routinely having a
daily case count in the 20s compared to
our current average of around 600 some
odd cases per day today to the relief of
our health care System covid
hospitalizations have been trending
downward after the hospital census was
over 300 for most of late December and
early January we are now seeing Hospital
census at around 250 individuals per day
our hospitals have worked
collaboratively to shift the burden from
some of the highest impacted hospitals
in Manchester nsha conquered but we are
yet meanwhile when we Look Backwards a
little bit to previous to the increased
cases we've been experiencing since
December we can see how clusters in
workplaces and among Gatherings really
impact thousands of New Hampshire
residents since the beginning of the
pandemic more than 7,000 New Hampshire
residents have tested positive for
covid-19 as a result of a workplace or
community-based cluster the data
snapshot that's on your screen right now
is from September to November and it
highlights that clusters continued in
every sector from Community settings
that include churches and sports teams
to restaurants to education and child
care settings and Health Care settings
such as hospitals and long-term care you
can see that in this time period the
greatest number of clusters occurred in
those Community settings but the largest
number of individuals with covid
occurred among clusters in healthc care
and in specifically in long-term care
care
facilities so here we are now you know
we are in a place right now that we are
seeing a more highly transmissible
variant of covid it's been detected in
over 20 States across the country
including Massachusetts Connecticut New
York Pennsylvania and Maryland The
increased transmissibility of these
variants that we've seen in the United
States and in other places in other
countries suggests that we need to keep
Vigilant with compliance with mitigation
strategies including distancing masking
and adherence to the safer atome
guidelines that were developed um with
the governor's reopening task force
again we are not quite out of the woods
yet but to keep us safe for now and as
part of our efforts to mitigate the
effects of covid-19 Public Health has
participated and in and provided
technical advice to our Governor's
reopening task force the public health
role was to support the task force as
they developed guidance for each
industry sector that is supported by
both science and
data the safer atome Universal
guidelines have provided the required
steps businesses need to take in order
to operate safely for their employees
and the public the guidelines have
evolved with the science and with
changes in the pandemic mic but focus on
keeping potentially infectious people
out of public workplaces through
screening and quarantine through
cleaning and disinfection through
modifications to processes and policies
including social distancing and the use
of masks and finally quarantine and
isolation requirements for those with
covid-19 or close contacts are the
structure that all of our businesses are
using right now to keep
safe the star of the show right now is
vaccine and I think that's the thing
most people are are interested and
excited about we at Public Health are
excited that vaccine is already in the
arms of more than 70,000 New Hampshire
residents including our healthc care
providers First Responders residents and
staff of long-term care just yesterday
uh 1,600 individuals were vaccinated at
one of our 13 fixed sites around the
state where we work in partnership with
the national guard and the department of
safety and others to make sure that we
have accessible vaccine in every corner
of the state by getting vaccinated each
of us help end the damage to the economy
and prevent more illnesses and death in
New Hampshire as we walk through some of
the highlights of New Hampshire's
approach keep in mind the following the
safety of covid-19 vaccines is a top
priority the two doses of vaccine right
now will help protect you from ID 19 and
there is currently a limited supply of
vaccine but Supply will increase within
the weeks and months to come but this
limited Supply right now is why we are
prioritizing some groups over others for
those first
Doses and finally the vaccine is
important but no one tool is going to
stop the pandemic your best protection
from covid-19 continues to be a
combination of not only getting that
covid vaccine when it is your turn But
continuing to wear that mask staying six
feet away from others avoiding crowds
Often by now most of you are pretty
familiar with new ham New Hampshire's
vaccine allocation plan as you can
imagine this has been a complex process
and decisions have never been made in
isolation our rollout philosophy has
been to keep people from dying to impact
those most vulnerable to the risks of
covid-19 and to keep our Health Care
system up and running so that it is
ready for all of us if and when we need
it with those goals in mind you can see
that we prioritized those most at risk
for the worst
outcomes in 1B we're focusing on
residents 65 and older and people with
significant health risks and we focus on
those that cannot social distance those
in our long-term care facilities and
Residences for people with intellectual
or developmental disabilities and
Correctional
Facilities vaccines are administered in
a variety of settings including our
hospitals within our healthc care
provider offices through pharmacies and
of course the state-run fixed sites like
the one we have right here in con ConEd
in the parking lot of the Steeplegate
Mall it will take a while to get through
this population of almost a quarter of a
million people but we anticipate that
we'll be able to move into phase two in
March and phase three throughout the
spring later in Spring and in the summer
The Limited vac supply of vaccines from
the federal government means that
appointments may be booked weeks out
everyone in phase 1B who wants an
appointment will get an appointment and
if allocation should increase
appointments will be rescheduled to
earlier dates and times 211 is ramped up
as a call center to help with
registrations for the 1B population and
those calls and that registration starts
this Friday we hope that most folks will
use our website but hundreds of state
agency staff and the National Guard will
be ready to answer the call come Friday
and in the weeks ahead we will be
prepared to answer questions and help
people um manage and get those
registrations moving
forward by this fall we hope that we
have a significant number of New
Hampshire residents vaccinated and that
Community spread will decline from the
numbers we see today if there is
anything we've learned during this
pandemic it's to be flexible to change
our partners the National Guard Hospital
hospitals long-term care providers
community members and the residents of
New Hampshire have been
extraordinary we are all eager to take
this next step from 1 a into 1B and
Beyond and as we get that supply of
vaccine we will get the doses out we
literally want to roll up our sleeves to
protect our families and our communities
and we want those most in need to be in
and if there weren't already enough
benefits to getting vaccinated employers
and employees should know that after you
pass the two week Mark from your second
dose of vaccine you no longer will need
to quarantine if you are identified as a
close contact or if you travel outside
of the New England states vaccination
provides a pathway to reduce the spread
of disease and to get back to some sort
public I encourage you to also check out
some of the excellent resources that are
available on our covid-19 website
including this FAQ for schools
businesses employers that was developed
by the attorney to General's office and
answer some of the questions that our
employers are wrestling with right now
in the cliffnotes version we are
strongly encouraging individuals to
protect themselves their family and
their Community you'll see confirmation
that the state does not intend to
mandate these vaccines and generally
does not recommend that these vaccines
be mandated for students employees or
customers there's a couple reasons for
that first of all there may be legal
complexity surrounding mandates for
vaccines approved through an eua which
is an emergency use authorization
through the
FDA there's also a question of equity
and fairness when neither of the any of
vaccines will be available to the entire
population at the same time we simply do
not have enough vaccine right now for
everyone and while it's generally not
recommended at this time however a
business could choose to require a
vaccine this is not unlike healthc care
providers who require their employees to
have a flu vaccine if a business is
considering this approach it must be
non-discriminatory in nature and
employers may be required to make
accommodations for employees under
federal laws such as the Ada or the
EOC if businesses are thinking about
going down this path they should do so
in consultation with their legal counsel
an approach we can all take is to remove
barriers for employees to access vaccine
that includes ensuring that people have
time of work to get the vaccine and that
people are
encouraged at the end of the day the
vaccine will protect our families save
lives and it will offer that pathway to
return to the Gatherings that are
important to us for our physical mental
health so what's
next phase B registration starts Friday
phase 1B vaccinations start next week we
are asking the public to take a look at
the vaccine website the vaccine.
nh.gov webbsite to see when is their
turn and they can go through a little
process there to click through some
buttons and determine what phase that
they likely belong in we know that phase
1B is a heavy lift there is between
250,000 and 300,000 New Hampshire
residents in this group and we hope to
have the opportunity to offer them
vaccine as we have it
available we also encourage all of our
uh residents of New Hampshire to call
211 as I noted earlier we have hundreds
of state agency staff ready to man the
phones working on it right now we have
National Guard folks helping us because
we know the interest is so great at this
moment so feel free to use tom11 now and
to use 211 as we start registration at
the end of this week and the beginning
of next
week and finally we ask you all to just
stay informed and I know that this
committee as much as any has been
watching closely through our Governor's
press conferences and through the
updates with Dr Chan and Dr Daly and we
have tried to be as transparent as
possible on our website to provide all
the information that folks need as we
know it so I will stop my share right
now and I will turn back on my camera
and I'm happy to answer any questions
that you may
have let me ask the first question
Patricia is it possible for you to go
back I think to your third Slide the one
which shows the 60 to 69 age group 70 to
79 80
plus okay let me pull that up right
there and I think you were which you
were for
shows the one with the number of deaths
per age group yes yes I will pull that
up for right now and here we go whoops
maybe not we'll go backwards this way I
think all of us are mastering zoom in
new ways these days here we go is that
the slide that you were interested in
yes thank you it shows the number of
deaths uh the 60 to 69 age group is is
so much and then the 70 to 79 is
probably about triple that and the 80
plus is much much greater than that and
at one time 1B group was going to be for
the vaccination was going to be 75 and
and above but it was just changed
recently to 65 and above and where it
goes to 65 and above
uh it's going to be very difficult for
those that are in in their 80s or in the
high 70s to comp compete with the ones
in the
65 a lot a very last group to get it and
they may end up being because they're in
this group may end up getting it at the
end of the group are you doing any
prioritizing within group 1B so we are
trying to do that and and um and first
of all thank you for that question and
you're very appropriate observation of
the data I think there's a couple of
ways that we've addressed this one is
working with our Pharmacy Partners um to
ensure that we have uh vaccine at all of
our our long-term care facilities and
that includes both our nursing homes and
assisted living facilities and we know
that they were our you know among our
number one population that was 1A it was
them and the healthc care providers and
our First Responders and we are thankful
that we have gotten at least first doses
out to over 126 of those facilities in
the state and all of them will have had
first doses by the end of January CVS
and Walgreens have been great Partners
CVS is taking care of about
75% of uh those long-term care
facilities and Walgreens is taking care
of another 25% but we think that that's
that population um certainly generally
um 75 and older so 70 and older and 80
plus um that are most at risk and really
as the data show most at risk of dying
from
covid-19 um I think the other point of
your question that we certainly have a
large number of folks that are uh 70
plus 75 plus that are not living in a
long-term care facility and as you noted
they're almost in competition now with
that 65 and older group um for getting
signed up um we are hoping to try and
make sure that that we have vacc
available to everybody who signs up um
we know that there is increased risk
from 65 plus um we know that um just a
week or so ago the federal government um
secretary AAR had recommended to all
states that we focus on that 65 plus
population um the other group that is
included in 1B is also the medically
complex those who are who potentially
are under 65 but had to have multiple um
medical conditions they are also
prioritized and we're working closely
with Healthcare Providers to um simplify
the way that we can attest to that so
the short answer to your question is
that there will be signups starting on
Friday um we have prioritizations within
the prioritized group of 65 plus um and
we are hoping to get as many vaccines
into the arms as many people in this
population as possible and as the supply
allows let me ask this followup is that
I I know of some people that are over 85
with at least a couple of these
conditions there uh when they sign up
will they be
prioritized if if if maybe maybe they
try to go on first thing Friday but they
can't get through until Friday night and
by yeah by then there was thousands of
them that already got ahead of
them yeah get prioritized we are we're
asking folks if they have questions and
they need help and they believe that
they should be at the the top of the
line again um we want you to call 211
they will help folks get through that
process we want to be able to be there
available to them um so that they can
get registered and then after they're
registered those um appointments get
made uh as well so the advice is use 211
rather than the going online you can use
you can use both but if you want to talk
to a person who will walk you through
that certainly you are free to call 211
second bring this up okay representative
Bry has a
question thank you good presentation
appreciate it um where Ways and Means as
you know we're charged with doing
Revenue estimates that's going to that
are going to be based a lot on how
quickly things are go back to normal and
you know as we know we have to project
revenues for July 21st July of 2021 to
June of 22 July of 22 to June of
23 uh by the middle of February so part
of the big question that we're going to
keep on coming back to is well when are
we going to hit her
immunity now I I listened to the
governor last week uh last Thursday and
he said New Hampshire was getting about
177,000 doses a week at currently when I
when I hear one B is 300,000 people is
that 600,000 doses that equates to to me
I did the math that'll take eight eight
over eight months to do about eight
months to do uh assuming that the number
of doses that we are given doesn't an
increase I guess question one is what's
the chances of us getting more doses As
Time Marches
on uh because the more doses equals the
the quicker more people will uh be
inoculated and and the number of uh you
know that's the more likely that the
state of emergency will end and th
helping revenues and the other question
I have is about this new strain that to
me that could be another fly in the
ointment in our thing is on ways means
uh do we know if the current vaccines
are effective on this new strain that's
great
questions thank you thank you
representative abrami you're you're
asking great questions around the supply
I'll start with that um you're correct
we are receiving about 18,000 doses a
week it is not enough to do all the
folks that we want to get vaccin vaccine
into the good news however is that we
expect that to increase we expect that
there are two other uh manufacturers
that are right in the wings that should
be coming up soon with supplies of new
vaccine as well one of which is a one
dose not a two dose so that's great news
most of us would love to have one one
shot in the arm instead of two shots in
the arm so we are um going to be
registering people out um we will be
using every single dose that is
available to us and we are hopeful that
the supply it will increase over the
next few weeks and certainly months
ahead of us as new manufacturers come on
board and receive their emergency use
authorization as well um we are anxious
to work with a a new Administration as
of today um to ensure that states get
Equitable supply of vaccine so that we
can reach all the people that we need to
reach I think we're all in agreement
that this is the this is our pathway out
um for both healthy people and healthy
main streets your second question about
the variant um certainly all of the
scientists are keeping a very um strong
look at this right now and watching the
data as I mentioned it's throughout this
the country right now it has been
identified in Massachusetts it's been
identified in New York we have not
identified one of the variants in New
Hampshire yet um we have the capacity to
do some of the genome sequencing to do
that work so we're getting ready um and
we have sent um particular samples to be
sequenced that have not um been
identified as being the variant so we
are certainly concerned um the science
as of today and the data suggest right
now that the vaccine will be effective
against the new variant the main concern
with the variants are that it appears
that they are more easily transmissible
so again we are all anxious to get as
many vaccines out into the community as
possible to limit that transmissibility
it's also the other reason why all of us
can't give up on that M you know I'll
sound like a broken record like Dr Chan
sounds like a broken record like the
governor sounds like a broken record we
can't give up yet on the masking of our
social distancing and staying away from
large crowds of people quite yet you
know we see the light at the end um but
we got to get there thank you Norm I
have one more question but I'll let
others go first and if there's time I'll
I'll ask it thank you thank you uh
Patricia
represent
elmy thank you I had a bunch of
questions too but on the first thing is
there as far as I've heard I've heard a
fair amount about this sorry about that
phone call on the on there is no
evidence yet that the people who are
vaccinated are not cannot be carriers of
covid so I do not understand how we can
tell people not to
quarantine once they've been vaccinated
completely on which is really going to
delay things for for our economy and the
other one is just following up on
representative major our chair on there
I haven't seen anything in the
advertising about this that would
indicate that you should call 211 if
you're over 75 or you've got a number of
The Chronic conditions and on I did use
your check and I'm over 65 I will be
over 75 two days before I was going to
be eligible
before um oh 65 to 75 is a lot healthier
than 75 on up uh and
um
the the people in our in that age group
those age groups who are at home which
is a lot of people uh really need to be
told that you should not use the
internet which I think is probably going
to crash the first few days uh but they
should go straight to 211 and try to get
through that
system but that or if if I mean all it
asked me was are you over 65 and then it
said great to come in uh there really
should have been are you over 65 okay
you over 75 over 75 we're going to give
you a appointment
sooner or with major health
conditions thank you so thank you
representative Aly I think you're
expressing uh a number of the concerns
that um certainly the public has right
now and I just want to be clear here um
your uh my recommendation to call 211 is
simply so that you can talk through the
process with someone rather than going
through the uh registration process
online and I know for many people that
is easier um for to be able to walk
through with another human next to you
uh or on the phone with you as you do
that work we understand that you know um
that folks over 75 may be at added risk
um we also know that there are risks
associated even among that 65 and older
group who may still be in the workforce
um and so it is difficult to balance all
of those different risks together um but
my recommendation is to call 211 if you
want to talk through that with someone
on the phone um the website um you know
we are we are uh very um we are putting
together everything we possibly can
right now all of the supports all of our
efforts are in making sure that both the
phone system and the website system will
be ready and not crash um come Friday
and through the weekend uh we are
dedicating a tremendous amount of
resources across state government to do
that right now so that is the piece that
we all have our not only have our
fingers crossed but we're putting real
effort into um making sure that we have
that ready again to your earlier qu your
first question around vacc after getting
vaccinated there is some small
indication um and again we need more
data and more time with more people who
are vaccinated to see how this really
plays out in real life um but there's
some small scientific possibility that
um a person who was vaccinated could
still H carry that um the uh Co Corona
virus um in their mouth and their
respiratory droplets which is why we're
asking everyone to continue to wear
their masks even if they are vaccinated
but it was a decision of Dr Chan and our
governor's office that
um because the risks are s so much fewer
so low much lower um that we would still
allow people that have had those two
doses of vaccine and then two weeks out
to be able to travel without quarantine
or to be able to um not quarantine if
they were a close contact we uh we very
much encourage all businesses in
particular to um make their own policies
that are perhaps more protective um than
our policies and where staff can work
remotely we're truly you know as we're
all doing right now calling in from our
homes or our offices where we're
separate we want to continue doing those
practices because of course that is the
most
protective thank you but now that we are
uh we have a 65y old level uh the only
way that you can get an earlier
appointment if you are severely uh
impacted by covid if you catch it is to
call up
211 um I I would not I'm not going to
promise that folks can get an earlier
appointment if they call 211 all I'm
suggesting is that someone will walk
them through the process while they're
there um again it is complex we are
expecting thousands of people to be
calling us early on this is another
place where you may also want to have a
conversation with your healthc care
provider so um there are at some point
um healthc care providers will also have
access to vaccine that they can do
within their offices um we are working
on the distribution of that right now I
don't have the exact numbers of how much
will be distributed to hospitals and
healthc care providers Primary Care
Providers at in addition to our fixed
sites so I encourage anyone who has
significant questions about their own
health um and if the vaccine is right
for them um and how they should access
that um to eventually call their healthc
care provider I know that the health all
of our Healthcare Providers right now
their phones are ringing off the hook as
well and they're trying to provide as
much information that they know given at
at the at the time that they know it um
the information has been we've gone
quick um we've provided um something
called Health alert networks to all our
providers so that they should have the
basic level of information and what the
plan is we've been doing weekly calls
with our hospitals um since the
beginning of the pandemic so that we
have good communic unication but things
change quickly um and um we we want
folks to make sure that they know that
um you know the first day to sign up is
on Friday um and we want to make sure
everyone has an opportunity to sign up
Ames
unmute sorry about that I gotta start
over again thank you uh and uh my
question is twofold one is uh um even
after listening to you uh speak about
the priorities and the opening up of 1B
in a couple of I guess very soon uh for
registration it's not clear to me what
the rules of the game are going to be is
it going to be a first come first serve
is there some other protocol that's
going to be in place where you live uh
what are the what are the variables that
are going to go into determining when
somebody um on who calls in is likely uh
to get uh
vaccinated um and the second
question
um is uh is one that flows from a
constituents letter that I received just
yesterday a married couple who are in
their U 6566 67 year old
bracket um they've served as teachers
they're
healthy um they are I'd say very upset
that they've been moved into a uh the
next Priority One B uh while
teachers and child care workers or
teachers uh remain in priority too in
effect pushing back teachers to a uh a
later time and uh they point out that
keeping our schools open is uh certainly
for all of us uh one of the top
priorities in this state uh getting them
open keeping them open whatever it is in
your local community um and so pushing
back teachers in this way um is uh is
very problematic from their point of
view and my question there is whether
this question of prioritizing of uh
defining the groups uh in a senseful way
is is open and still being worked on
within the circles that you're working
in uh and I would certainly put in a
pitch for the teachers myself um so
that's basically it I think ultimately
uh the
supply uh of vaccination is going to uh
determine a great deal of what uh can be
done and I know you've mentioned that
several times I wish I had a better
understanding of how we go from 177,000
or 18,000 doses
today um to whatever a week from now or
two weeks from now again what are the
variables what's the information that
you're on top of receiving or that you
hope to receive soon that relates to
that so I've I've uh there's a lot in
there I'm sorry but uh very yeah thank
you and I'll I'll try and pick through
some of those um the questions that
you're asking there I'll start with
Supply um again we are hopeful that new
manufacturers are coming on board we are
also hopeful that the there will be an
increase in both the fiser and the Mna
vaccine that we have right now we are um
the federal government is sends the
allocations to the states so we are
dependent upon them for those
allocations but having another two
manufacturers on board is certainly
going to be helpful and help us move us
closer to that goal question about
teachers and um this is near and dear to
my heart um this is these are you know
it goes without saying that these are
complex ethical questions that we have
wrestled with with and we have wrestled
with it from the beginning of the
pandemic and certainly now as the rubber
hits the road once the vaccine has been
available around who goes first in line
and I think New Hampshire has solidly
come down on the notion that the right
thing to do right now is to focus on
those who are most at risk for the worst
of the outcomes associated with
covid-19 as we looked at that slide
earlier where the deaths are the deaths
are among people aged 60 and over um we
know that many of the schools and the
child care providers in particular who
are fa who are working daytoday you know
a lot of our schools are remote right
now and working hybrid which we all
agree is not optimal for kids or for
staff um but we have childcare providers
who are working daytoday with kids um on
the floor in a toddler room so that
their parents can work and and I know
that is the Ways and Means Committee
that that that's important to you all as
much as anything that that's critical to
our infrastructure which is why they are
among the only sort of critical
infrastructure group that is called out
in our plan we needed healthc care
providers called out early so that we
had a Health Care system for all of us
um so that we would not crash our health
care facilities and those folks that are
most at risk including our First
Responders and then the next group that
is an industry group that was called out
were teachers and child care providers
no no other uh critical infrastructure
groups um were called out in in that way
so we recognize that it's going to be a
little while we need to have that Supply
um we are focusing on the age groups the
65 and older again the the people who
are most at risk of dying and having the
worst outcomes and worst
hospitalizations and being on
ventilators we know what group that is
and so that's that's the decision um
that many folks came to right now uh how
we got to that decision certainly is a
combination of a few things one we have
a state disaster medical advisory
committee that is a group of um medical
providers Physicians and others who help
us think about the ethics of these of
this decision making and they certainly
provided a tremendous amount of feedback
and we work with our team of inous
disease specialists and Dr Chan and
certainly our governor's office to to
land in the in the order that we're in
right now um I think I I lost your first
question there and I didn't write it
down um but I think I hit both teachers
I think I hit the supply um question
first come first come first serve isue
or what what the protocol will be for
yes so thank thank you for the reminder
on that we are still working some of
those things out so part of the reason
you're not hearing a very clear answer
from me right now is that those are the
details that are being um determined
right now um and we anticipate that the
governor is going to have his um press
conference tomorrow where he's going to
be able to dig in a little bit deeper
into those details so um again the team
is working very hard at this minute to
make sure that we are successful and
that the people who should be first in
the line are first in the
line thank you okay um representative
southware am I unmuted
yeah hi thank you for all your efforts
um I just wanted a clarification so um
you'll sign up um which probably means
uh personal information your email stuff
like that then will you basically get an
email with an appointment and something
you print yes so you will sign up you
will then find out that you are
registered you'll you'll get a
confirmation that you're registered and
then later you will get an email with an
appointment date um you you know when we
did this with our First Responders and
the health care providers the Ambulatory
Care Health Providers they were um our
first to go at using this process and so
what we found was sometimes um we were
able to turn around um appointment times
very quickly sometimes it took you know
upwards of a week or more to get a
response with the excuse me with the
appointment time so again those details
um folks are working around the clock
right now to make sure that our system
is up and ready we are all committed for
it to go live um by Friday um and so
there will be more details to come and I
anticipate when the governor and um Dr
Chan and Dr Daly do their press
conference tomorrow you will get to that
level of detail uh thank you and do you
have a time for that press conference is
it usually at 5:30 or 6 or something um
I don't have the time directly my
understandings it's typically a little
bit earlier in the afternoon
okay thank you thank you
representative bar me yes thanks Norm uh
real quick um so what's the end game
here um what kind of metrics are going
to be in place to say that we've won um
is going to be a combination of cases
deaths hospitalizations number of people
vaccinated is it everybody is it going
to be zero uh zero cases or has that
been thought through yet so I and I'm
ask to have a crystal ball here but
we're we're struggling to understand get
kind of a timeline and what would have
to be in place for uh the restrictions
to be loosened a little bit and for
businesses to really start coming back
to normal absolutely thank you um
representative arami I mean you are
asking the million-dollar question of
you know when will we know um we
certainly know it's not today um are we
anticipate that the cases are Contin
continuing to be high as I noted you
know we're in a very different place
today than we were this summer where you
know we were routinely talking about 20
cases a day and now we're talking about
600 or more cases per day um the good
news is is that um our both the science
has gotten better and Medical Treatments
have gotten better so um we can treat
covid um more effectively today than we
did last year at this time where we had
such high death rates where everyone who
was you know at that critical age we we
at that critical stage when they were in
the hospital so um we know that folks
like Dr fouchy and others have said 70%
is sort of the end game for vaccination
that people would love to have as a goal
for getting vaccinated in order to have
some more control of the spread of the
disease um we don't know how long it'll
take to get there again it's a complex
mixture of metrics of supply of how you
get those um vaccine here and how fast
we can get it out into the arms of other
people but um we anticipate especially
with the new variant that we're going to
continue to have some high numbers for
some time now but as we see people um
vaccinated we should see those numbers
come down and I think then is when folks
like the governor's office and our
reopening task force and others are
going to wrestle with that question of
when will it be time to start loosening
up on some of the protocols that we have
in place today we know it's not today we
know we need to get through a lot of
vaccine first okay thank you would see
uh Norm it would seem that would be
great if we could uh touch Bas with uh
Patricia and others from the Department
of Health periodically As We As Time
Marches on here just to so we get a
you we'll have her follow up on that uh
uh representative Aly and followed by
representative
Tor yeah mine's on quick now I think on
when we sign up on on the website will
we be asked to put in our age and our
conditions great thank you so um you
will likely need to put in your age you
will need to put in a birth date likely
and and um the medical conditions um are
we're working closely with our healthc
care providers because they are going to
provide some
attestation um and have a form that they
will need to sign um that will attest
that uh this that the individual has the
conditions that they say that that they
have two or more conditions uh it is
unlikely that we'll be tracking the
exact conditions that people have but
certainly that they meet the threshold
of um of that medically vulnerable group
and again more details on what it's all
going to look like um I think will be
available um tomorrow um and again I
apologize for not having that
information today but we are we are
literally working on it as we speak so
that it's ready to go and I I don't want
to um promise something that or or
describe something that may change
between now and
Friday so we are going to put in our
medical providers at least um if you are
um if you have the that medic you fall
into that medically vulnerable
information uh or medically vulnerable
category now if you are simply age
appropriate um you will not need to
provide your medical information so if
you are 65 or older that will be good
enough as the as the vaccine phase
Checker um as you used on the website
doeses you know you hit 65 plus and you
know you're automatically in in group
1B
and this is also um in part um you know
we want to reduce the burden as much as
possible on the health care providers as
well um you know we want them to uh we
know that this is a huge lift for them
and we are very grateful to their
partnership because they now have to be
working with their panel of patients um
especially those who are under 65 who
have those medical conditions they want
to be able to make sure that they can um
take care of those folks as well as
older representative um t a great
presentation I'm all set uh
representative elme got my question
answered for
me okay and that was the last
one well Patricia I mean s had
your number of
questions representative major I'm sorry
to interrupt um um but representative
Edwards raised his hand in the attendee
panel I know we're we're quite away over
time but I just wanted to bring that to
your attention in case you wanted to
question represent
Edwards just a
moment okay representative Edwards you
can unmute and
speak okay uh Miss Tilly it's always a
one wonderful event hearing you um you
you use the term partnership
with our uh health care providers
because we know how much workload that's
getting put on them I just would like
you to know I've had three different U
Family Practice type people one PA and
two doctors reach out to me and say that
the workload being imposed by the
vaccination program is intense it's
breaking them it's costing them a lot of
money so so it's good that you you're
saying you're going to do what you can
as a department to reduce the workload
burden but I just want to hear a little
bit more about the appreciation that
this isn't a partnership This Is Us jam
refuse thank you representative Edwards
um there is no doubt that this is
burdensome um we know that um and I use
the term partnership it is not a
euphemism it's true appreci app ation
for the work that we can't do it without
them I think we all share the notion
however that we want to get folks
vaccinated and we want to prioritize
those that are medically NE medically
vulnerable um and we have to have some
process to do that um so part again part
of the conversation of reducing to 65
plus is that may relieve a little bit of
Burden again to certify whether folks
are medically vulnerable or not because
they meet the category if you're 6 and
older you check you're in you're in that
group um we know that people have
intense relationships with their medical
provider so we know that even if we said
don't call your medical provider people
would still be calling them up on the
phone because we have such um long-term
relationships with them and especially
those of us that may have um multiple
medical conditions we want to know from
our medical provider that this is the
right thing to do um so we appreciate I
I don't know how much more can say that
we appreciate the work that that um that
is in front of them right now it is a
burden for all of us to move forward to
move quickly at the pace at which we are
moving during this pandemic it has been
an extraordinary time so thank you in
the interest of time I'll just say
you've answered my question completely
thank you thank
JN I don't see any more hands no Okay so
so uh we thank you Patricia and I'm sure
that you're going to get a lot more
questions before it's all over and I as
I said I encourage everyone there will
be more information available tomorrow
when the governor has his press
conference and Dr Chan and Dr Daly will
be able to lay out a little bit more of
the process you you got me like a a day
or two too early to to have all of the
details available for prime
time okay for the members that are me of
the house Ways and Means Committee next
Tuesday and
Thursday we will have another U virtual
meeting all day and on uh the 26 which
is
Tuesday we'll be meeting with agent
agency head starting at 9 o'clock with
the legislative budget assistant then
the Department of Revenue the lottery
liquor then launch judicial branch
Department of Health and Human Services
Secretary of State and Department of
Justice then on Wednesday starting at
9:00 there'll be the insurance
department Department of Safety
Department of Transportation fishing
game
lunch Department of administrative
Services Treasury Department Department
of Labor and Department of Agriculture
and markets and that'll be our schedule
for next week
rep of major this is Chris could I just
interject for a second yes on Wednesday
you took the Department of Agriculture
and Department of Labor off the schedule
we were just going to have
administrative services and Treasury
Department speak to you that's right
well we're going to end with the
Department of administrative services
and the treasury Department yes and just
so members know um as we get the
presentations from the agencies we've
asked asked them to provide that by um
Thursday this week um what we will try
to get them posted on the same website
page that the presentations were for uh
today and yesterday and we will have an
email sent out to you as well um to let
you know that they're
available um as you've noticed with the
past two days not all the presenters get
us everything um on the days that we've
asked for them for different reasons so
we will get them up on on our website as
quickly as we
can and that's all I have for the moment
okay and then just for the
future on the second and third of
February we plan on having
uh agency heads in
again I'm sorry agency heads on the
second and then work session we'll start
February and that's it for right now
then uh we'll go from there nor B yeah
uh are you going to are we going to do
bills on the 28th and on the 4th is that
something you've announced or going to
announce okay right the other day I
mentioned that on the 28th for the Ways
and Means Committee we'll be having Hees
uh
hearings on one two three four five
seven bills one is an early bill and the
others are primarily associated with the
budget the bills that we're going to be
hearing on the
28th is House Bill
15 House Bill
353 House Bill
568 and that will be a uh a hybrid
arrangement we have three other days the
4th 11th and 17th of February that I'm
asking for but it hasn't been finalized
yet where
we plan on hearing all all the rest of
our bills there'll be either six or
seven bills each of those days those are
the bills that are currently in
committee we will be getting additional
bills in the committee because we
anything that has to do with revenues
that went to a policy committee ahead of
time they passed the the session will
come to us as the second committee bill
now the bills that will be hearing
initially we may have to have a
committee of as a whole to go into these
bills because there's questions and
things that need to be done with
them it's recommended that we do not go
to subcommittees because they don't have
enough room to do
subcommittees so uh we will bundle them
together and uh committee as a whole to
deal with them what we normally would
subcommittees and we'll go from there
and then as as we can we'll do our
executive
sessions what we also want to do is is
try to identify those bills that we feel
need a lot of work and they and they
should that work should be done would be
candidates for
retaining retaining so that
hopefully next year will be back in a
normal environment and we can do these
in a correct
way all
right so we have our work cut out for us
the goal is is to come up with our
Revenue estimates shortly after the
governor presents his budget from
revenue
estimates to the finance
committee once that happens trying to
and making arrangements to have the
governor's budget director meet with us
to
explain
his Revenue estimat so we'll have some
intelligence on what he did because in
his Revenue estimates might be uh
revenues that are more than what current
LA is when we do our Revenue estimates
is just based on current law so that we
can pull out out of his Revenue
estimates things that would
require uh rate uh rate changes or
additional Revenue
sources and we'll get that
February any
questions if not then I just have one
has a
question yes representative model
um I just got an email saying there's a
training tomorrow morning for committee
chairs and techs is that the is Tech the
thing I signed up to do yes it is oh
okay thank you so committee clerks and
texts um it said training for committee
chairs and texts oh okay all right Zoom
training for yeah I was thinking of
represen a NN scene because he he missed
a training for clerks because we had
this going on so yeah I've been in
contact with the clerk and we're gonna
work out an alternative Arrangement okay
good so tomorrow morning is okay all
right and representative Olie has a
question as well represent major yes
representative you said earlier that you
will be sending this stuff out by uh
email so we can put it into our Outlook
calendars and where the meetings are
going to be held and how they're going
to be held and all that lovely
stuff right um the meetings next week is
just strictly
virtual except for the hearing and I'll
get a
hearing I talked to the clerk today and
they're working that out
so and once I find out what the in room
is going to
be will notify you by
email and it should go into it should be
week any other
questions all right thank
you thank
you